become a student with leadership study
it read about it watch things about it
practice it every day be a parent you
know like join the movement means I'm
going to take care of my team sometimes
I'm in a leadership position and
sometimes I'm not and it doesn't matter
I'm going to practice leadership if I'm
a salesperson if I work at the check
Encounter of an airline I'm going to
take care of the people I work with I'm
going to take care of the customers as
if they're my family practice leadership
learn about it study it because I do
these things because I recognize I'm
just a piece of a jigsaw puzzle because
my job in this movement I'm the guy who
points at the box but I need lots of
people to join me who say I have a piece
of the puzzle I'm willing to lead this
way I'm willing to lead with an infinite
mindset and put their piece down and say
how can I help build that Vision we need
the Army and so how people can engage in
the movement is actually practicing all
the stuff more than anything else that's
what we need need motivation watch your
top ten with believe Nation hey it's
Evan Carmichael and I make these videos
because in my first business I was
making 300 bucks a month I quit on my
business partner and the thing that
saved me was studying the stories of
super successful entrepreneurs so I hope
that this story today helps give you the
motivation you need because I still
needed to myself so today let's learn
from one of the best Simon sinek and my
take on his top 50 rules of success
enjoy
the best leaders are actually the best
followers in what ways what do you mean
um the best leaders never think that
they're the final that the buck stops
with them they always believe that
they're in service to something bigger
than themselves and even if that leader
uh the person in leadership position
gets to the tippy top of whatever
organization they still feel that
they're subordinate to something even
bigger right so uh uh the Pope
does still thinks that he's in service
to something bigger than than him right
a CEO of a Visionary organization
feels that they are still beholden to
and in and following a vision bigger
than them so the best leader is actually
the best follower is even if they're at
the highest levels of the organization
they're still in service right it may
not be to a person but to a cause an
idea a vision whatever it is there's
still some sort of something that
they're beholden to and they're devoted
to and they're in service to
um so so followership is a thing
um and
um
not to belabor the Marine point but uh
uh you know Marines when they evaluate
their leaders they're looking good for
good leadership and good Fellowship so
for example there when you go through
OCS officer candidates uh School
selection
um uh
when somebody's a for a task you know
chosen to be the leader of that group
for that task the the Marines are
watching the others as well so they're
looking to see that everybody's
contributing ideas and they're looking
to see that that leader takes in those
ideas but is decisive and and they're
looking to see that the the members of
the group if their idea isn't picked
they still give their all
to see that that the leader's idea is
successful and if it fails give it their
all to pick up the pieces and see what
they can do as opposed to I told you
right should have gone my way right I
was right or sabotaging because their
idea didn't get picked so they go all in
so so good followership is is as
important as good leadership that that
we we respect that that
um when a decision is made we will we
will give our Blood Sweat and Tears to
see that the decision our leaders have
made will be successful and if it fails
we will help pick up the pieces because
that's the deal one thing make them work
together
um uh I shared incentives is also a part
of thing usually all we do is give
individual incentives which means we're
only incentivizing Behavior to work
individually
um
uh and by the way incentives don't
always have to be Financial it can be
just recognition and reward you know
catch people doing things right so when
you see people helping each other and
sharing call it out publicly you know
complement publicly criticized privately
um uh in front of the rest of the team
um give people promotions when there's a
behavior that you want to promote like
like teaming
um but also ask people to solve problems
together and and thank them together and
if one person comes to you and complains
I'm doing all the work you say well why
don't you find out what maybe they're
struggling maybe they're like we have to
push push back
um uh and also I think the most
important thing is leading by example
um asking for help I mean when the
leader acts like they know everything
and they have all the answers then all
it's doing is telling everybody else you
better know everything and have all the
answers because that's how you're going
to get ahead here and so I think one of
the most difficult things for anybody in
a leadership position to get comfortable
with is is saying I don't know or I need
help or can somebody help me or can you
do this with me
um I love working I love teaming with
folks on on my team it doesn't matter
what the rank structure is bring in
someone Junior let's work together
um even if all they're doing is poking
holes you know do you think this is good
no I think it can be better okay let me
try again
um so I think I think demonstrating the
behavior that we want is a big part of
it heck man I've disagreed with my own
ideas you know I
is wonderful and and
kind of like falls apart they're just
like okay yeah I kind of screwed the
pooch on that one yeah but I take
accountability yeah you know or we find
in the middle somebody goes hey if we do
this we can probably be more successful
and we pivot there's there has to be at
the decision-making ranks there has to
be a humility that the ideas don't
always have to come from me right Bob
Gaylor the fifth chief Master Sergeant
of the Air Force is the best definition
of humility I've ever heard he said
don't confuse humility with meekness
humility is being open to the ideas of
others so you know it's not about like
oh shucks that's not humility you know
you and I know some remarkable leaders
people of great power and authority and
they have huge egos yes you know they
know they're good and they don't mind
talking about how good they are but when
somebody says hey I got an idea they
lean in like they're little kids they go
let's hear it you know I'm looking at
some of the photographs on your wall and
some of the folks that I know here they
have an insatiable curiosity for ideas
and even though they're unbelievably
accomplished if you have something to
share with them they want to talk about
it they want they want to hear about it
that's humility to me you know so it's
not this you know it's not me it's you
know
self-confidence is a good thing thinking
you're better than everyone else that's
unhealthy oh that's good yeah you know
thinking you're good is healthy thinking
you're better than others is unhealthy
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all of the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video app absolutely for free
there's a link in the description below
go click on it and start building the
momentum in your life and your business
I'll see you there what are your
thoughts around courage how do people
get the courage to to play the long game
to not the long game it's the infinite
game because a long game could be five
years right true yeah this is forever
uh how do people build that everything
that we're talking about in the infinite
game is really really really really
really hard
it is so much easier to build a company
based on short-term Ambitions than it is
an infinite cause it just is right it's
also fun right until it's not
um less inspiring but sometimes
sometimes fun right hitting a goal feels
good right
um it's much easier to just hire and
fire people frequently higher fast Fire
fast as to hiring slowly and and firing
slowly because we we try and take care
of our people as best we can it's just
it's hard to build teams all of that
stuff we talked about leadership like
what am I supposed to do to build a
trusting team well I wish I could give
you a list of five things it's really
really hard to be a parent
it's much easier to be an uncle or an
aunt or not have kids right it's hard
right so why do it you know it's fun and
and exciting to be to try and beat our
competitors you know but to to have to
face our own weaknesses every day oh
that's exhausting you know existential
flexibility I'd rather not I just would
rather not
you know so so the reason this takes
courage to completely change our mindset
a about the game that we're actually
players in
um and how we want to approach these
things and do we want to shift our
mindset and our organizations to prepare
for the infinite game to be organized
for the infinite game it takes courage
because we're going to be swimming
Upstream in a world that is very finite
driven you know the pressures on us are
overwhelming from Wall Street or our own
egos or from internal incentive
structures or our bosses whatever it is
the pressures are overwhelming for us to
play the finite game
and so how do you stand up to massive
external pressure courage
and courage is something that comes from
relationships
you know it's external a a world famous
trapeze artist would never attempt a
brand new death-defying act for the
first time without a net
they would never do it so why do we
think that we could do something
difficult without external support too
um I've had the opportunity to meet real
heroes people who've risked their lives
to save the lives of others with the
belief that they were going to die
and they didn't and when asked why did
you do it they all say something similar
which is they would have done it for me
it's external and so we have to have we
have to take the time to Foster and take
care of people around us to nurture our
relationships because when we're going
to be doing something difficult when
we're going to be swimming Upstream when
we're going to be innovating and and and
and doing something different there are
days we're going to doubt ourselves
there are days we're going to get
knocked on our ass there are days that
storms are going to rise and we have to
have people who say I got you back
you need to do this
we need you the world needs this keep
going I believe in you you know
um and so courage courage comes from
from not only our willingness to do that
for others but then their willingness to
do it for us and if we commit ourselves
to a just cause and we're willing to to
do those things then
you know the great thing is we take a
lot of people with us and change the
world for the better and isn't that sort
of the the point of an infinite life to
leave this world in better shape than we
found it to leave the companies that we
work for in better shape than when we
started to leave our families stronger
and better capable than than what they
can do without us you know isn't isn't
that what it means to live an infinite
life that we can live literally live on
beyond our own lives we take
accountability away from people and we
don't even realize it yeah so we're
actually destroying people's confidence
or ability to make decisions because we
keep answering their questions or making
decisions for them I had a boss many
years ago one of the best leaders I ever
had Peter and DiMaggio and
um he wouldn't answer a single question
I asked it drove me absolutely nuts hey
Peter you know what should I do well
what do you think we should do well I
I'm I think we should do this he goes
well you should give that a try then you
know or he would just ask me questions
he goes well have you considered this I
went no it goes well maybe think about
that you know but he was never tell me
the answer he'd always tell me the
parameters
um what he told me was self-reliance it
was the most valuable lesson I probably
ever ever learned
um very often you know somebody will
come and say you know should we go with
blue or green
I'll go with green well we just answered
the question once I go with the one you
think we should go with
what should we do here make the decision
you think is the right decision to make
you know and then let them make the
decision and when we give people
accountability the amazing thing is they
rise to it yeah but we keep taking the
accountability because we keep answering
all the questions so there's a very easy
lesson for everyone here is
um stop replying to all the emails that
you're getting while you're away
right like I know what happens you know
in every break or
right now uh you know there's an email
that says you know should we go with
this one or that one and you're replying
and in every break you're going to reply
to all your emails and you tell people
your opinion of what you think they
should do versus saying I'm going away
for a few days for this conference so I
can learn to be a better leader
um hold down the fort while I'm away
if there's an emergency figure it out
you know
um or only call me if you absolutely do
not know the answer
um and stop replying to all the emails
and they now have to work you're giving
away uh responsibility one of the
reasons they don't take responsibilities
because they don't give it to them how
do you develop
self-confidence we're kind of going off
here now but I'm this is a topic I'm
really passionate about right now I
believe uh self-doubt is one of the
biggest Killers to anyone's Dreams yeah
so how does someone develop
self-confidence and sustain it with the
ever going changes and stresses and
uncertainties that always come up once
you reach a certain level there's a new
uncertainty no
so I think it's ironic that we call it
self-confidence
because I don't for one think it comes
from the inside
I think our self-confidence comes from
the outside
right that's the wrong way of going
about it or you think that's where it
comes from in general
that we are being misdirected by the
name
when we say build your self-confidence
that's the instruction is saying go
inside
look inside oneself but I think that's I
think that's I think that's a false
Direction children aren't born
self-confident
their confidence is built from their
parents and their friends and their
teachers
where they're rewarded when they do well
and they're pushed when they fail
when they can do better simply you know
we know this that simply telling kids
that they're great all the time actually
doesn't build self-confidence actually
does the total opposite right right
um and I for one I can tell you my in my
own experience my own self-confidence
um uh a hundred percent comes from the
relationships that I have
um it's not some deep internal fortitude
you know a world-famous trapeze artist
is not going to try a brand new
death-defying act for the first time
without a net
so it's the people in my life
um it's it's when when I do doubt myself
that somebody says you got this
when somebody says
I believe in you when somebody says no
matter what happens whether it succeeds
or fails I'm going to be by your side
that's when I have the confidence to do
difficult things wow right I don't have
some natural battery that I that just
right you know that that to me is
bravado yeah I don't know about
self-confidence you know you know
being a huge risk taker
is not an indication of self-confidence
to me you know jumping out of a plane
and jumping out of a plane with a
parachute are two different things right
right
um
um to me self-confidence is measured and
there should be a degree of of of Doubt
um but but I I think true
self-confidence belief in oneself and
belief in one's cause you know I could
not do the things that I'm doing and I
would not have the strength
um to have made the sacrifices that I've
made or continue to wake up on a daily
basis to drive to spread this message
um if I were alone and so when we talk
about building one self-confidence I
think the mistake that we make is that
we look inside I think the reality is
when we try to build our self-confidence
we should be looking to our friends we
should be nursing our relationships when
I'm looking to build my self-confidence
the question is who around me do I need
to take care of you know the way we bit
our self-confidence is by helping
somebody else build theirs right it's an
act of we will build our confidence with
an act of service depending on the size
of the organization obviously
um uh it's very common that other team
members will go to the leader and say we
don't want to work with that person I
mean that that's usually a big highlight
you know
um uh that's frequent
um uh you can tell in meetings very
often if somebody is domineering but I'm
also a great fan of peer reviews quite
frankly
um uh the the Army Rangers dealt with
this they called them Spotlight Rangers
when when candidates were going through
Ranger school they had to in the past
they had this issue where these very
talented Ranger candidates and the T and
the instructors love them so they looked
like they were great candidates the
problem is as soon as the spotlight was
turned off
they were horrible people so leadership
didn't know
and so they implemented peer reviews so
now you have to be good at your job your
instructor has to like you and your
colleagues have to like you you're
you're and so
um and by like I mean respect and you're
you know you you're seen as a team
player and help each other out so um if
all you're doing is reviewing annually
someone's performance
that's insufficient there needs to be
regular feedback mechanisms and there
needs to be an open open dialogue and
peer review 360 review where you all
come into a room and you get to give
each other feedback in real time
um but yeah it's probably because there
aren't enough metrics what is your
advice for somebody that's in a company
that they they don't have an infinite
minded culture don't don't be there no
don't try and influence that which you
cannot influence don't control that
which you cannot control
you know an infinite mindset means
that is something I can do but I can
influence and take care of the people to
the left of me and to the right of me I
can take care of the people who work for
me I can even take care of the person I
work for sometimes we have a toxic boss
not because they're bad but because we
don't understand the pressure they're
under sometimes to Simply exhibit
empathy to our boss you know hey boss
you were really harsh on us today
everything all right
what's going on I'm worried about you
you know
um I'm here like we can we can succeed
together I'm we're here to help you you
know if we're no matter where we are and
inside an organization leadership is not
about rank or authority leadership is
taking responsibility for the people
around us and so any anybody on any team
at any rank at any level can be a leader
the first choice is that we have to want
to be a dear friend of mine Lieutenant
General George Flynn from the Marine
Corps said that the first Criterion to
being a leader is you have to want to be
one
um so any of us can volunteer to be a
leader
um and that's what you do you commit
yourself to seeing that the people with
whom we work on a daily basis love
coming to work they feel that someone's
got their back they feel supported they
feel that they have top cover they feel
someone cares about them as a human
being listens to them knows their story
allows them to be themselves we can be
that leader and what you start to see is
those teams becomes really high
performing those teams become super
tight and you start to hear rumors
across the company because everybody
wants into that team because apparently
it's a great team to work with to work
on
um and before you know it one of those
people goes and moves to another team
and they take everything that they learn
because leadership is learned and they
do it for another team and if we take
that infinite mindset
and eventually the tail will Wag the Dog
and it doesn't matter if it's this CEO
or another CEO because we will Outlast
whoever's in charge right now and that's
the goal we're doing this for the good
of the organization we're doing this for
the good of the cause
right and the tale can whack the dog
leadership and Authority are not the
same thing
title affords you Authority affords you
rank right
um but that doesn't make you a leader I
know many people who sit at high levels
of organizations who are not leaders
um we do is they tell us because they
have authority over us
but we don't trust them and wouldn't
follow them anywhere
um and we I know many people at low
levels of organizations that have no
formal rank no formal Authority but
they've made the choice to look after
the person to the left of them and and
take care of the person to the right of
them uh and we would trust them and
follow them anywhere
um and so rank affords you the
opportunity to lead at scale
it affords you with the opportunity to
take care of more people Implement
systems and and incentive structures and
all the rest of it and reward behaviors
to to to to to you can influence culture
with rank but that doesn't make you a
leader and you still have to study the
the the the the tenets of leadership and
and and when they align it's magical you
know when you have Rank and you and
you've been studying leadership then you
can then you can actually affect the
culture in a in a more robust way and
and one of the primary responsibilities
of any leader is to make more leaders
and and you can do that at scale if you
have authority I get asked very often
you know what are the most important
characteristics of leadership vision
Charisma you know I know plenty of
incredible leaders that aren't Big Steve
Jobs Visionaries you know they're just
not and I know some fantastic leaders
who do not have Charisma they're quiet
and super introverted you know and
they're just not that exciting to talk
to spend time with
um
uh
when I say Charisma I mean the
traditional definition yeah which is
more about energy I believe charisma's
undying belief in something and that
they have in Spades but I think courage
I think courage is the one thing that
all great leaders have to have because
we are surrounded by overwhelming forces
every day of Our Lives pushing us to
play the finite game you know if you're
a public company the the markets all
they want for their own selfish game is
for you to make short-term decisions the
pressures are overwhelming
um
if you're a numbers driven person the
pressures are overwhelming if you're in
survival mode the pressures are
overwhelming if you have a spouse who
spends more money than you can make the
pressures are overwhelming uh all the
pressures around us even the way we
treat competition versus rivalry like we
feel like we have to win win all the
pressures every day on us are absolutely
overwhelming for us to be finite and to
to prioritize the short term over the
long term to prioritize the Urgent over
the important and it takes unbelievable
courage to put the important before the
Urgent it takes unbelievable courage to
resist all the pressures coming from
selfish outside parties it comes it
takes unbelievable pressure to do the
right thing how can we ensure that we're
changing with times technology culture
politics and tastes
um rather than just trying to beat our
competitor and you see it across
Industries uh you know uh publishing for
example
um you know the internet showed up and
they they saw it and they thought it was
nice and they you know as it took on
they sort of I guess they were
interested in it they sort of played
defense and then Amazon showed up and
Amazon went to all of them and said hey
you want to invest in this and they all
said no well now they're all playing
catch up they're all playing defense you
know Netflix went to Blockbuster and
said want to buy us and Blockbuster said
no the rest of the TV and movie industry
were too busy comparing who had higher
ratings and they completely missed the
fact that Netflix is now completely
reinvented television
um I find that fascinating General
Motors was destroying its own electric
vehicles in a in a to protect its old
business and now they're all rushing to
catch up with Tesla I think this is
hilarious and it's the little companies
the Netflix is the Amazons the Teslas
that get ignored that aren't seen as a
threat that end up defining and
redefining entire marketplaces now this
is not unique to small companies big
companies can absolutely redefine the
problem is big companies are more
obsessed with their finite goals big
companies are more obsessed with beating
their competitors and little companies
are obsessed with their Vision little
companies are obsessed with this
outsized Vision that outstrips the
resources they have right somebody says
we're going to do this and everybody
looks around and goes we don't have the
money for that we don't have the talent
for that I guess we'll have to be
creative
and I think this is one of the
opportunities for big companies as they
get big their Visions get smaller they
become goals that they can just do a
back plan for there's nothing inherent
that a big company shouldn't be
Innovative but to your point before they
become risk-averse
they become stable
um and at the end of the day it takes
huge Vision what I imagine is a huge
corporation a multi-billion dollar
corporation that someone will say we
imagine a world that's so crazy and so
idealistic that in this large
corporation they all look around and go
we don't have the money for that
we don't have the talent for that I
guess we'll have to be creative
which scares the heck out of
um uh the investor Community but
remember all of those companies were
founded by you know whether it's your
Steve Jobs or all of all these companies
Salesforce they all started by young
people who had no experience and only
had Vision
um and I think that's there's no reason
why big companies cannot uh cannot be
Innovative but I think
it's about pushing their own boundaries
and allowing for entrepreneurship and
inherent in entrepreneurship is
failure you can experiment without
failing I remember talking to a CFO of a
big company once and he told me that he
has two priorities for the company uh uh
uh Innovation and efficiency
I I said good luck with that you know
there's nothing efficient about
Innovation because you have to keep
trying something over and over again
there's nothing efficient about that and
for some reason I don't know what it is
companies are obsessed with growth
and everybody they brag we're a hyper
Growth Company show me one article not
10 not 15 show me one article that shows
any data that hyper growth is good for
business and good for the company
there is no data to show that companies
are obsessed with growth actually build
stronger companies because they don't
and so it is a Fool's errand that is
promoted usually by an incentive
structure that rewards short-term
benefits I think what companies can do
is start to look at their incentive
structures and start rewarding things
like teamwork ethics and and long-term
gain and guess what you'll get the
behavior year reward find a friend you
love and you know one of those people
who if you called them at three o'clock
in the morning you know they take your
call and you would take theirs
don't do this with a spouse don't do
this with a sibling uh uh don't do this
with a boyfriend or girlfriend those
relationships are too close
but find a best friend and ask them this
simple question
why are we friends
and they're going to look at you like
you're crazy because it's very hard for
the human brain to put our feelings into
words because the part of the brain that
controls our feelings doesn't control
language this is why we use metaphors
and analogies and why we struggle to
tell people how we actually feel it's
because it's a different part of the
brain and so they're going to look at
you and be like
I I don't know why are you asking me
this and you say come on I know you've
been there for me uh my whole life and
then you actually stop asking the
question why ironically you actually
asked the question what you say come on
what specifically is it about me that I
know you'd be there for me no matter
what and they're going to hem and hog
because it's hard to put into words
don't help them don't let anybody else
help them and they're going to start
describing you I don't know you're funny
you're smart you're honest you've always
been there for me you go good you play
Devil's Advocate good that's the
definition of a friend what specifically
is about me that I'd know you'd be there
for me no matter what and again some
will get through this quickly and some
will get through it slowly and it'll be
a struggle and you have to continue to
play Devil's Advocate good that's the
definition of a close friend what
specifically is about me and eventually
they'll give up
eventually they'll stop describing you
and they'll start describing themselves
like my friend said to me Simon I don't
know all I know is that I can sit in a
room with you I don't even have to talk
to you and I feel inspired and I got
goosebumps in fact I'm getting them
right now they will put into words the
value you have in their life and you
will have the emotional reaction you'll
either well up with tears or you will
get goosebumps this puts you in the
ballpark this is where your why lives
and if you do this with multiple friends
they will say the same kind of thing in
in fact sometimes they'll say the same
exact thing because your why is the
thing you give to the world and amongst
your closest and best friends it is the
space you fill in their lives so that's
a fun little way you can find your Why
by ourselves as individuals we are not
very good we cannot lift heavy weights
by ourselves and we cannot solve complex
Problems by ourselves but in groups we
are remarkable
um and so all of this stuff whether it's
life whether it's whatever your job was
in the service whatever your job is out
of the service whether it's finding a
new job whether it's making your way
finding out sort of what your passion is
all of these things are incredibly
difficult they're all incredibly
complicated and the person who thinks
that they can tackle any of these
problems by themselves is a fool plain
old you're a fool you cannot I'm going
to tell you you cannot do it alone and
so asking for help is perhaps the
greatest single thing anyone can ever
learn especially where everything is new
and the stresses are different and uh
and and often feel overwhelming and
scary totally unfamiliar and the longer
you are in the service
the scarier it is
because this is you had 15 years doing
one thing knowing one thing learning a
culture and now
not only is it new people don't even
understand what you did and what you
know the military is one of the most
misunderstood cultures in the world it's
so closed and insular that people just
don't know it so you're dealing with
that as well and so to ask for help
in any form
is brilliant I this is the single thing
that
completely transformed my own culture I
had a small business I quit my job and
started my own marketing consultancy a
bunch of years ago and for a few years I
ran on force of personality and it was
great but then if you have a little bit
of a little bit of success force of
Personality doesn't work anymore and all
of a sudden things started crashing on
in around me because I couldn't I
couldn't do it all
and I thought I had to know all the
answers and if I didn't I pretended that
I did because I thought
that's what I had to do
and I learned I learned the very very
hard way where I came it was a dark
period that I had to learn to ask for
help and and I it turns out I was
surrounded by people who wanted to help
me they just didn't because they didn't
know I wanted it or needed it and it was
the willingness to ask for it or accept
it that transformed my life
um and put me on the path that I'm on
now now I'm really open about I can tell
you stuff I'm really good at and I'll
tell you I'm good at that and I'll tell
you I am not good at that I need help
with that if I'm struggling or if I'm
stuck if I'm confused I say can I ask
you I call up friends I call it people
mentors and say I need your help can you
help me and here's what I've learned
about the building of trust we don't
build trust by offering people our help
we build trust by asking people for help
that's what actually creates trust
because it's an expression of
vulnerability right it allows people
us to offer us safety and protection and
that's an act of service for the other
person the tension is healthy the
tension is good
um you know if all you have is empathy
then you have a hippie commune and
you're not actually going to cure
anything but if all you're doing is
driving the numbers driving the numbers
uh you're gonna have a short life span
and break the machine also and you might
have a spike and then you'll disappear
or all your best people say I I hate it
here and they go work somewhere else and
take all of their their their their
Brilliance somewhere else
um so you there is a balance but there's
also a hierarchy you know it's not 50
50. there's no such thing as 50 50. it
doesn't exist you can't say well we're
50 driven by performance and 50 driven
by culture because you will face
decisions we're one of those things has
to SAC will sacrifice the other now
which one the question is which one are
you going to choose there has to be a
bias towards people there has to be a
bias towards uh the teamwork the
environment
um and the will to to to succeed is
driven by the belief in the cause
um uh uh you know if if if the cause is
clear and the metrics and you're letting
people see the metric so they feel they
feel like we're making progress again go
back to that Marathon analogy right
which is
you're exhausted you're tired but you're
getting close to the Finish Line you
start running faster not slower that's a
good point
um uh and so uh it's it's it's keeping
people included to know what the metrics
mean and um and which ones are trending
and which ones are absolute but yeah
there's nothing wrong with the drive to
succeed as long as there's a context
within which uh within which that drive
exists when we are willing to put
ourselves at risk to be there for
someone right don't worry if this goes
south I will be there for you
um which may mean working late it may
mean working extra hours it may be
putting our reputations on the line I
mean there's a lot of things that that
takes
um but when we genuinely promise to be
there for someone
um
um uh and and it has to be genuine uh
because if it gets tested it's very easy
to find out if it was genuine or not
um but if it's genuine then then it's
repaid remarkably let me give you a
silly example
um let's say that um so I talk about
this um sometimes which is the giving of
time and energy is more powerful than
the giving of money you can't build
trust with money so paying somebody
bonuses and giving somebody a big salary
though feels nice is not earning or
building any trust whatsoever you cannot
pay for trust
um and here's the example
um let's say you're moving house
um and one of your friends says you know
what I want to help you we've been
friends for years
um I'm gonna pay for the moving van
here's five thousand dollars and the
moving van let me know how it goes have
a great move that's really generous
right
another friend says you know what I want
to help you move and they come over the
week before and they're sitting in your
house packing boxes they're
sweat dripping down their brow they're
there with you all day they're there to
help load the truck they're there to
help unload the truck they're they're
there
um uh to unwrap everything right they
paid zero money
they give you time and energy which are
non-redeemable Commodities money we make
money we spend money we make money back
it's a redeemable commodity time and
energy are non-redeemable Commodities
and so when someone gives us something
that they cannot get back
it has a much more powerful effect on
how we feel so now both those people
call you another time and say I need
your help which one are you more apt to
help you want to give you money or the
one who gave you time and energy and
that this this is a good lesson for
leadership as well giving our time and
energy is often more powerful than
simply just throwing money at someone
let's say there's one person who started
their own little business a little
consultancy right got my shingle out I'm
a consultant right and everywhere they
go they keep telling you that they're
better than everyone else
uh they keep telling you they're smarter
than everyone else they keep telling you
that you know the big the problem with
the big companies is is they don't have
the flexibility I'm it actually gets to
the point of being annoying to the point
that we don't want to actually work with
them because we don't believe them right
um because
um now let's let's change the change the
scenario you meet that same person and
and they introduce themselves look
there's a lot of good good Consultants
out there
um some of them are a lot better than me
um but I wake up every single day to be
a better version of what I do today than
I did yesterday and I can tell you the
device I give today is even better than
it was yesterday and the advice I'm
going to give tomorrow is even better
because for me it's an education and
that's why I love working with
open-minded wonderful clients who are
partners because what we end up doing is
growing together
right now that's one person think about
how appealing that person is they've
actually told you that you may actually
get as good or better advice somewhere
else but it's who they are and who
they're being in the disposition that
they bring that makes them way more
trustworthy and uh us wanting to work
with them
um and it's the same for big companies
it's got nothing to do with the size of
the company which is it's called
humility and honesty I remember young in
my career I experienced this myself when
I when I went off uh and hung my shingle
out and I was a little I had a little
marketing company a little marketing
consultancy I remember going into
meetings and the client would say we
want you to do all of this for us and
I'd say I'm really good at that pretty
good at that okay at that really bad at
that I highly recommend you hire
somebody else to do that and I'm happily
partnered with them for them to do that
and the clients wanted to work with me
more
not even though I just told them I can't
do that only because I was the only one
who was honest everybody else they talk
to big or small told them that they were
great at everything which is just not
true nobody's great at everything and uh
and so it's amazing when you take the
risk to be honest it pays dividends and
the trust that you build you have to be
clear and open about what you stand for
and just like when you hire somebody
you want to make sure that when you hire
them that they share your values that
they believe in your vision you know
they don't just think it's corny you
know or marketing
um but rather that they they buy into it
and sometimes we'll make mistakes and
sometimes people will come and they fall
in love with it after the fact but we
it's you know we try on balance to bring
people that we believe will get along
with the people who work here because of
our values and our and our cause and so
too is it with with with suppliers
um I think that um uh or or clients it's
the same thing which is we stand for
what we stand for and our goal is to
attract people who believe what we
believe the the more vocal we are about
what we believe those people literally
will come to us or turn down a
competitor who may even be cheaper
because they would rather do business
with us and so it's okay to do business
with a supplier that doesn't believe
what we believe but we have to go in
with eyes open knowing full well that
this is just a transaction you offer a
decent product you give me a decent
price this is not going to be a lifelong
relationship this is a transactional
relationship
and when it's done I'm just going to
hold you to very different standards
right because when it's transactional
we're a little less patient when things
go wrong
um
and sometimes we kid ourselves you just
can't do that too often it's like if
you're living a healthy lifestyle you
can have chocolate cake just not too
often
um so yeah I think the more vocal you
are the more you attract and then you
have to make decisions like you're
hiring people because they're going to
become a member of your family as well
this is the difference between the
short-term finite minded and the
long-term infinite minded
um the finite-minded is it the cheapest
today is it the best relationship today
and pay no attention to the secondary or
tertiary effects and definitely pay no
attention to what will happen in five
years whereas that long-term minded
infinite-minded uh player
um looks at some it's it's looks at
something and and looks at someone and
says well you know you're not the
cheapest but I think we're going to get
along just fine and over the course of
time the quality of work will far
outweigh what have you paid a friend of
mine who's a consultant loves to joke
about her clients that they never have
the time or money to do it right the
first time but they always have the time
and money to do it again
and I think when you're infinite minded
you consider those factors from the from
the beginning if I ask you do you need
to change and you said to me no I'd be
worried you know like you think you
figured everything out like emotionally
professionally all your relationships
everything's golden oh okay how's that
working out for you you know I think the
answer is always yes which is to view
ourselves or our organizations as Works
in progress you know that is an infinite
mindset uh infinite mindset is
fundamentally constant Improvement so
you know there's big change there's
little change there's tweaks there's
dramatic change sometimes it's reacting
to changing cultures uh changes in
culture politics technology you know
sometimes the change is our own
sometimes we have to react to it but I
think the honest answer is yes we have
to change there's always opportunity to
improve something
foreign
so there's this notion in businesses
that people fear change which is just
fundamentally not true people fear
Sudden Change you know
um but incremental change is not
threatening people feel fear change that
threatens them right and very often the
way we change manage uh is we do lots of
PowerPoint presentations about what's
coming and don't worry and we have all
these things and we we treat it very
rationally and what we're ignoring is
the emotional response now there are
some people who who love change
um yeah it's a it's an infinite minded
thing to embrace uncertainty to see
opportunity in surprise for some people
especially people who have been who have
gotten good at doing something for 10
years 20 years
um that all of a sudden you'd say you're
gonna change it they fear again there's
that emotional word they fear that
um they won't know how to or it will set
them back and so no number of of
rational assurances will help them get
over that at some point we have to just
let them go through the process we Bandy
these words around a little too quickly
these days they all kind of mean the
same thing you know authenticity and
tension you know purpose flow all these
things you know of course it matters
what is the what is the birth of this
motivation is it for PR is it is it to
hire Millennials because that's what
they want so we'll give it to them you
know uh uh is it is it because the
street demands it is it is it because
it's something I fundamentally believe
in I'm I'm very for with the round table
announced the statement's a bit pablum
but you know it reads like a you know
the generic values that put on the wall
of a generic company
um uh I would have liked to have seen
them the people who they attribute the
work to in the press release to folks
like Kip Tyndall from Container Store or
Jim Senegal from Costco who've been
leading this way for decades and have
been outspoken about the way business
has been done and been criticized for it
for decades like they're better
Messengers for it because they're deeply
they have that deep intention they
fundamentally believe business should be
done this way and the true
infinite-minded player
wants to build a business not just to
Build a Better Business for themselves
it's they want to build a business
because they want to build business
better so they don't just come up with
an idea and then hoard it they come up
with idea and share it because it's good
for the game it's about perpetuating the
game so if the intention is to see All
Ships rise then then I'm very open to
what these these companies are saying if
the intention is to see our ship rise I
become a little cynical so there's
another guy who does what I do uh he's
extremely well respected he does
extremely good work
um
I hate him
oh it's he's always been very nice to me
when I've seen him professionally just I
have an irrational hatred of him
and uh whenever his name comes up I like
it drives me nuts like people bring it
like we're we hired him and I was like
uh and and because I'm because I hate
him uh I'm really competitive with him
and so I will go online and look at my
book rankings and I'll immediately check
his and mind you I don't look at anybody
else's just his and uh if I'm ahead I've
got this like smug feeling and if he's
ahead uh I get really pissed off you
know
um so anyway we had the opportunity to
speak at the same event I don't mean
like me in the morning him in the
afternoon afternoon like we were
interviewed together on the stage and
the interviewer thought it would be fun
if if we introduced each other
and so I went first
and then I looked at him and I said um
you make me really insecure
um all of your strengths are all of my
weaknesses
and when your name comes up it makes me
really uncomfortable
and he looked at me and he said funny I
feel the same about you
the reason I had such an irrational
hatred of them had nothing to do with
him it had to do with me he's my worthy
rival his strengths revealed to me my
own weaknesses and instead of
confronting and taking a hard look at
myself and evaluating those weaknesses
and working on those weaknesses it was
much easier to take all of that negative
energy and direct it towards him in
other words to be competitive to want to
beat him right it was a very cathartic
experience
we've since become very close friends
have worked together I no longer check
his book rankings and because we share
the same cause we can actually work
together
um and so and so what I recognized was
so often in business we have these
competitors sometimes on our own teams
that we want to beat them we've all had
the experience where one of our
colleagues got a promotion and we got
upset we got angry we got angry at
somebody else's success think about that
for a second why couldn't we share in
the joy right what is it about them
that's being revealed in us that's the
problem right and so having worthy
Rivals instead of competitors
competitors or other players we set out
to beat
but the problem with that is there's no
Finish Line
and so we're obsessed with beating the
other company
then at some point sure you're ahead in
whatever metric you chose until when
right at what expense at what cost uh
that's not sustainable but rather the
other players inside our industry
outside our industry on our own teams we
can choose our own worthy Rivals their
strengths reveal to us our weaknesses
and by having our weaknesses revealed to
us it means we have the opportunity to
grow and improve and the infinite game
at its core is basically a game of
constant Improvement and so our our
worthy Rivals reveal to us our
weaknesses and our opportunities to
improve when you're trying to build uh
trusting teams it's you you recognize
that you cannot enforce certainty uh on
people you can offer goals people like
goals
um but what's important is how we get
there not not just that we got there
think of it like think of it like um
trying to lose weight right there's
nothing wrong with setting arbitrary
goals or with arbitrary dates which is
by the way how we build our businesses
we want to hit x amount of dollars in
Revenue by probably the end of the year
because that's when we pay taxes it's a
completely arbitrary number her somebody
might say we could do better than that
you're like you're right and then we
change the number right complaint works
of fiction that so we're striving to hit
a work of fiction right
um
um and it's the same when we want to
lose weight I want to lose x amount of
pounds by X date arbitrary right and
we're doing all the things to do that
we'll you know we're exercising eating
well all the things we love standing on
the scale we love a metric there's
nothing wrong with that
um human beings need that we can't run
in a marathon without mile markers it's
actually unnerving we need to know how
fast and how far so the metrics are good
and let's say you hit your goal right
you hit your performance goal just as as
as you uh had articulated amazing you
feel incredible you feel like you've
succeeded here's the problem you have to
keep exercising for the rest of your
life right in other words you don't stop
doing the things that you were doing so
the game hasn't ended it was simply a
waypoint but what I think is more
interesting is what happens if you miss
your goal what happens if you don't lose
the amount of weight that you wanted on
that date and the and the answer is
nothing nothing happens because you're
probably way healthier than you are now
than you were you're probably on the
easily you can see the trend data you
can see you're well on your way to
hitting your goal you just pick the
wrong date you're easily going to hit it
in another month if you just stick to
your regime business is the same which
is sometimes we miss our goals but the
question is how what's the trend data
you know is the team working well
together is morale High
um is some of it out of our control you
know market conditions and things like
that things we didn't we didn't know
about and so if we happen to miss the
number the problem is how are we
rewarding our people and so many of us
only reward Our People based on if they
hit the number but what if they're
begging borrowing and stealing what if
they simply Rush at the end of the
quarter to to drop their prices or have
some sort of promotion or or or have
some some trickery they'll hit the
number
and then we bonus them which tells
everybody else I don't care how you hit
your numbers as long as you hit them
well guess what kind of behavior that's
going to reinforce inside our
organization whereas if you look at the
data the trend data and you reward
somebody who's well on the path what
we're telling you is as long as you're
doing a good job you'll do well in this
organization
leaders understand that they are not
responsible for the results they are
responsible for the people who are
responsible for the results and that
skill set is very very different than
just trying to get people to do the
thing that you know how to do better
than them because you've been doing it
your whole life when the pandemic struck
I mean my book came out a few months
before the pandemic and so for from a
from a for someone like me who like who
loves to observe and like whether this
stuff is true or not you know you sort
of go you know you sort of Wonder is
everything going to hold up or not
uh and as an existential Flex uh is
something that I predicted would happen
either zero once or at the absolute most
twice in a career but when covet
happened we all went through it at the
same time existential flexibility is is
that you're able to make a profound
uh 180 degree strategic shift in order
to continue to advance your cause in
other words stay relevant
um this is not about the daily
flexibility of business this is we're
talking profound strategic shift here
um and sometimes brought on by pandemic
sometimes brought on by changing
technology or politics or culture or
tastes
um but you're able to adjust
um so for example it's um Apple Steve
Jobs when they're developing technology
in One Direction they just and they
discover this thing called the graphic
user interface that they did not invent
and they decide to walk away from
millions of dollars spend an accountless
man hours in order to focus on a
different uh strategic uh position
because jobs believe that that was a
better way to advance his cause of
empowering individuals to use uh
personal computers
um that's that's existential flux how do
we replace our judgment with curiosity
um so there's a simple technique there
are simple techniques to do this one is
write yourself a little reminder put a
little sticky on your computer that says
be curious or ask questions you'll be
amazed how well that works but
especially in times when we're judging
especially when we're in groups of
leaders we're in meetings you know we
can snowball into judgment really
quickly let's say someone's performances
in Decline immediately they're lazy you
know they're stupid they don't
understand they're a problem child all
it takes is one person to break that
judgment and say well maybe they're
going through something and there is a
technique where when you believe when
you start to form a narrative about
someone or about something that you
force yourself to come up with 21
possible Alternatives of what could be
going on in their life so are they lazy
absolutely that's absolutely a
possibility are they a problem child are
they toxic absolutely are they going
through is are there kids struggling at
school maybe do they have problems in
their family maybe someone's sick maybe
do they have medical issues that they're
hiding from us that that they're too
embarrassed about maybe like my point is
is can you go through through the
exercise of writing 20 or 21 alternative
stories of what could be happening and
all of a sudden we find ourselves
talking about and treating that person
differently and it doesn't just come
about people it's also about decisions
we're making at work and all again in a
meeting all it takes is one person to
raise a question of what if
um and uh as Leaders The more we start
uh asking each other and ourselves what
if or what are the opportunities what
are the possibilities we'll find
ourselves doing that with our people
um that when they come to us instead of
us correcting them and telling that
they're wrong raising questions but
believe it or not simply having a little
reminder to be curious is is really
important first and foremost we have to
understand that there's no such thing as
certainty of outcome and this is why
this is one of the this is a huge
difference between finite mindsets and
infinite mindsets right a finite-minded
leader is afraid of surprises and does
not like uncertainty which is why they
like to work work in very short time
frames because you can actually affect
quite a lot of certainty if you only
think quarter to quarter maybe year to
year but if you start thinking in five
and ten year increments we all know we
have zero control over those outcomes so
finite minded players like to play with
very short time frames because it makes
them feel better even though the game is
infinite so it's actually again sort of
a stupid idea
um infinite-minded players Embrace
uncertainty and find opportunity in
Surprise and so where something goes
wrong or different and just as an aside
I got such a kick out of when covet
struck you know everybody was talking
about during these uncertain times
newsflash all times are uncertain
there's never been a time in history
ever that was certain all that happened
was something that we didn't expect took
place that reminded us that time is
uncertain and for the finite minded
players the immediate reaction was Panic
right
um what am I going to do how am I going
to survive and try and double down on
the old way of doing things hoping that
if I just did it more or at least
attempt to do it online that I would
that it would survive right the more
infinite minded players and this has
nothing to do with stress we can still
have high stress with the with with what
was going on but the more infinite
minded players saw the sudden change in
their business and saw and thought Oh
okay this is an opportunity what can I
do with this and instead of doubling
down on the way they used to do things
but doing it online they said okay the
times have changed the way I operate my
business have changed all the things
that I used to be able to do like having
lunch with people can't do anymore
so given what I know now if if I was
starting from scratch I have something
really valuable and important how would
I build my business today to still
provide the value to the people who are
looking for the thing that I offer
and that was their mentality their
mentality was very entrepreneurial their
mentality was very creative
um and they though it may have caused
stress there was an appreciation for the
opportunity one of the nice things about
the infinite game is two players or more
who sell basically the same product for
basically the same price for basically
the same quality can all be wildly
successful at the same time like no one
wins
um and and remember we're deciding the
metrics so we could decide that it's
market share or revenue or profit and
we're making these arbitrary comparisons
to arbitrary other players and we can be
all high and mighty about ourselves you
know General Motors decided that um that
market share was the thing and they were
obsessed with being number one in market
share meanwhile they were losing money
hand over fist year after year after
year not sure if that's a very uh
infinite minded Focus uh because you're
clearly going to put yourself out of the
game remember when when Circuit City
went bankrupt Best Buy didn't win
anything
um if anything they had to change the
way that they played because Amazon
became a much more dominant force in the
industry and so they couldn't actually
do the things that they used to do and
this is what it means to be an infinite
player means you understand that it's
not simply about repeating the same
thing that's always worked but it's
adapting with politics and culture and
technology and it's not actually about
competing against another player on in
the field but the only true competitor
in an infinite game is actually yourself
how do I make my product better this
year than it was last year how do I give
better advice this year than I gave last
year how to become a better leader this
year than I was than I was last year and
it's a constant constant education of
constant constant Improvement I can tell
you a funny story which uh you'll
recognize from the book which really
captures the difference between a finite
and infinite mindset and it comes from a
personal experience
I had the opportunity to speak at an
education Summit for Microsoft and then
a few months later I was asked to speak
in an education Summit for Apple now
this was back in the Steve Ballmer days
when Steve bomberen men ran Microsoft
and at the Microsoft Summit the vast
majority of the executives spent the
vast majority of their presentations
talking about how to beat Apple
Balmer at the time was obsessed with
beating Apple
um at the Apple Summit a hundred percent
of the executives spent a hundred
percent of their presentations talking
about how to help teachers teach and how
to help students learn one was obsessed
with their mission the other one was
obsessed with beating their competition
guess which one was struggling with
issues of trust cooperation and
innovation
um so at the end of my talk at Microsoft
they gave me a gift they gave me the new
Zune when it was a thing this was
Microsoft's response to the iPod
and again there's plenty of uh evidence
and footage of Balmer talking about he
was going to beat the iPod and this was
going to be the best product ever and I
have to say this little piece of
technology was quite good it was very
user friendly it was it worked very well
it was it was it was a really nice
little product
um at the end of my Apple talk I was
sharing a taxi with a senior Apple
executive and I couldn't help myself I
happened I just had to stir the pot uh
so I turned to him and I said you know
Microsoft gave me their new Zune and it
is so much better than your iPod touch
and he turned to me and he said I have
no doubt
and the conversation was over
because an infinite player understands
sometimes you have the better product
sometimes they have the better product
sometimes you're ahead and sometimes
you're behind the goal is not to beat
your competitor the goal is to add to
yourself
where Microsoft was obsessed with
beating apple apple ignored Microsoft
and was obsessed with doing itself uh a
year later Apple introduced the iPhone
which rendered both the iPod and the
zoom completely obsolete listening is a
trust building exercise
right if you've if you're in a take it
down to a personal relationship if
you've been in if you've ever had a
romantic relationships a loved one right
um
um making someone feel heard
doesn't mean you're wrong saying sorry
doesn't mean you're wrong it just means
you take accountability for your for
your actions and I think it is important
that when somebody objects to
vaccination that we don't demonize or
villainize them but we attempt to hear
them make them feel heard doesn't mean
we have to agree but they have to feel
heard and you know
listening is not hearing the words
you know it's making the other person
feel that they were heard it's it's it
we don't get to decide when when hearing
has happened when listening is that they
do and and by the way it's not 100
successful either you know because some
people are just hell-bent on and it and
but that's a minority
and so I think the exercises sitting
down with people and say tell me tell me
what's what you're going through tell me
what you're afraid of I I want to
understand because we're trying to make
everyone safe I I wanna I wanna hear
what what your thing is and let them
tell their story we have no answers
we're not there to object we're not
there to react we're not there to fix or
tell them that they're wrong women are
better than this than men
um uh uh uh
uh
and I think that has to happen and it
can happen simultaneously they're not
mutually exclusive
um I'll give you one one example
which is I have a friend who uh
refuse to get vaccinated
and I sat down with her and I said
tell me tell me your reasoning
right
she goes well
um this new technology like I don't
wanna we don't know it hasn't been out
long enough like we don't know so what I
hear is fear of the unknown
okay I go go on and she I let her talk
and say her thing and explain all the
things and I and then and I simply said
so you're afraid of the MRNA technology
right yes and I want them screwing with
my DNA
I said well just so you know it's 20
year old technology but then I found
something I could agree with her but but
you're right
it is the first time it's been
commercialized
you're absolutely right that's the first
time we've put it in the market so I
affirmed her fear
and then I said do you get flu shots
every year she goes I do I said okay
Johnson and Johnson is a good
old-fashioned flu shot it's a different
technology it's not mRNA so I you're 100
right if you're afraid of of the new
technology don't get modern or Pfizer
but Johnson and Johnson is it's just
like a flu shot it's the same old Tech
and she went it is and it is she went
and got a modern shot
[Laughter]
she just wanted to be heard because most
of her friends when she said I'm not
getting vaccinated he yelled at her told
her she was stupid told her she's an
idiot told her she's letting her friends
down told her she's making other people
sick told her she's a risk to society
that doesn't make somebody's mind open
up all I did was let her feel heard
I think we do we can't we have to do
that we don't have to like our jobs
every day but we do get to love our jobs
every days like you don't like your
children every day but you love your
children every day so having a a hard
day you know that that's fine but the
question is is what do we fall in love
with and at the end of the day the
reason
um uh that we Stay or Leave a job is
because how we feel about that job you
know I think we we misunderstand when we
think people just leave for money if
they just leave for money that they
never really had strong feelings at the
company in the first place right because
when people feel loyal to the company
they turn down jobs that offer them more
money or if it's so tempting and the
numbers are so high then they go to
their company and say listen I was
offered this job it's very tempting
there's a lot of pressure but I don't
want to lead is there anything you can
do to help me stay right so and you and
there's the point is is they're they're
open about it and and what makes people
want to have that conversation like I
said is that they're seen and heard
um the best companies
um have all kinds of programs inside the
company to help the person grow as an
individual now we talked about you know
listening skills and these kinds of
things these are valuable for the work
that we do but it turns out that those
skills also help us as parents they help
us as as as spouses or as boyfriends and
his girlfriends these are valuable
skills in life
you know
um and I think that we forget that we
talk about hard skills and soft skills
as if those things are opposite it's a
terror I hate the term soft skills hard
skills and human skills and the more
that we invest in human skills in
addition to the hard skills that we're
teaching the more people feel like
they're growing as individuals I have a
better version of myself now than I was
when I started at this company because
the company is actually helping me on a
in personal growth
um uh WD-40 which is a company that I
admire their their culture uh the
lubricant company
um uh they train their managers to be
coaches so literally like Executive
coaching training that kind of thing but
they train their own people to do to
have that skill set so that they're
equipped to help their people who have
challenges and especially with younger
generation you know the younger
generation is asking companies to
provide everything you know we want to
have our sense of belonging our sense of
community our sense of personal growth
our sense of purpose to come from where
work it didn't used to be like that 40
years ago and so and so there's a huge
pressure on companies and so I think
what entices people into the company and
into the industry is not just come and
do cyber security you know there's a
percentage of people who are you know de
facto interested in that but rather tell
them the kind of experience they're
going to have tell them what they get
from the company and you'll find it
remarkable how many people will all of a
sudden be interested in the in the
category in the company because of what
they get holistically not just what they
get from the product as a leader
um our responsibility is to make the
people feel that we have their backs and
actually have their backs
um so uh there's a sort of a nice
anthropological if you want me to go
down this rabbit hole
I find it fascinating there's a nice
anthropological explanation which I
actually uh explained in that book
um which is which raises the question
why do we have leaders
um human beings are naturally
hierarchical
um we self-organize all the time it's
got nothing to do with whether you have
formal hierarchy like in an organization
we we're constantly self-organizing like
in a sports team who's who's the better
player we self-organize we pay we pay
deference to the one who is better you
know the scientist who publishes more or
the Nobel Laureate well the other
scientists pay deference right
um uh this is not by accident
um there's a very good anthropological
reason for it going back uh many years
you know human beings have only been
farming for the past 10 or 12 000 years
but we existed for tens of thousands of
years on the planet before that and we
lived in populations that were about 150
we maxed out at about about 150 which
raises a very interesting question we
they lived in austere times people are
hungry
um somebody you know brings back some
food to the tribe we all rush in to eat
um well if you're built like a football
player you can shove your way to the
front of the line right but this is a
bad system because if you punch me in
the face this afternoon I'm probably not
going to wake you and alert you to
Tanger tonight
um and so it's it's just a bad system
for cooperation which is if we leave
every person to themselves
um and so we evolved into these
hierarchical animals we're constantly
assessing and judging who's higher in
the pecking order who's the alpha of the
of the group and when we assess that
someone has Alpha to us we naturally
step back we naturally defer and allow
our Alphas to eat first
um um and we uh get fed later and I
don't get an elbow in the face right
good system
this has survived to this modern day
there's not just not a single person on
the planet absolutely zero who has any
moral anger who is offended by the idea
that somebody more senior in the
organization makes a higher salary
or get to nicer office or a better
parking space it offends nobody now we
may think they're useless at their job
but the fact that they make more money
than us because they're higher up in the
organization offends zero
um if you're a senior and you leave your
coat in the other room someone will go
get it for you if you're a junior and
you left your code near the room you get
your own coat in other words you get
treated differently
and this is why people want to get
promoted because they like the perks but
the perks don't come for free and that's
the point which is as you make your way
up the hierarchy as you achieve that
Alpha status of the tribe there's an
expectation that sure will give you
first choice of meat and we'll give you
first choice of mate but if danger
threatens the tribe you're going to be
the one who runs head first towards that
Danger first to protect us which means
you might die first right that's why we
gave you first choice of mate because we
want to keep your genes in the gene pool
we're not stupid
and and it's When leaders uh shirk that
responsibility that we start to have
moral outrage so for example nobody has
a problem with a CEO making more money
than they do the problem we have is when
you're willing to lay off your people to
protect your salary to protect your
bonus rather than find other ways to
protect the people this is what Marley
offends us we have we made a deal
there's a deep-seated anthropological
deal that we've made with our Alphas
that you have to protect us you have to
and you have to do what it takes
sometimes sometimes putting your own
interests second
um and then and then you can but if
you're willing to do that we're proud
we're happy go enjoy you've earned it
um and so I think this is this is a
large part about building trust which is
it's not just about saying nice things
and being trustworthy it's that people
feel that you actually have their backs
and that you would be the one who take
responsibility take accountability look
for other ways to protect us if it meant
um we're gonna get hurt one of the
things we have to remember is that just
because
um the business can function with a
distributed Workforce with an online
Workforce
um we know that there's a sacrifice you
know it's harder to build trust you know
if you if you've joined the company
during covid you've never physically met
any of your your colleagues or
co-workers you know and you know it's
much harder to build trust when we don't
meet each other we take for granted that
we go to the office that you know the
little brief interactions we have at
work where you walk past somebody in the
hall and say hello or the talk going
into the meeting and the talk coming out
of the meeting and bumping into somebody
building oh I meant to tell you
something or do you want to grab a
coffee know one of these things by
themselves does anything but over the
course of time they contribute to the
building of trust to the building of
Human Relationships in an online context
we don't have any of the in-between all
we have is the meeting we log on WE log
off that's it and so what a lot of
companies
um um haven't recognized is that
building Trust online is possible but it
actually requires more work what used to
happen just relatively organically now
has to be now has to happen
prescriptively so for example
um I'm a huge fan of the Monday morning
huddle we do one on our team we're on
Monday morning the whole team comes
together
um and it's there's no discussion of
work or deadlines or workloads or
anything it's a human call where we
simply say what's on your heart and mind
and then we answer some funny or
poignant question that's posed To Us by
the person who's leading the Huddle that
month
um and and we simply talk about
ourselves and you learn a lot about
somebody you know somebody'll say oh I
had a great weekend with my kids and we
went you know we went hiking I didn't
even know that they had kids you know or
somebody will say to be honest it was a
really hard weekend
um my father has cancer and he's in the
hospital and he took a turn for the
worst and uh and we start to see each
other as human and we start to empathize
and we start to create relationship
and we start to get to know each other
but it's done prescriptively we make it
happen
um I'm also a huge fan of of turning on
a zoom for example and just working like
we're not actually working with each
other we're just in each other's screens
as we're getting our own work done it's
nice to have somebody there I'm also
believing about a huge fan of the
telephone
um you know zooms are tiring especially
when you have them all day
um you know it's fake uh you know very
often you know I'm looking at a DOT at
the top of my screen so that you'll
think I'm making eye contact with you
but really I'm just staring at the dot
at the top of my screen or if I'm
staring at you sometimes the placement
of the camera in the screens what you
see is this but I'm looking right at
your eyes you know
um and so I think a telephone believe it
or not is actually a much better way to
connect with somebody especially when
someone's distracted when you can see
that someone's doing email you know
while you're talking there's no actual
polite way to say can you stop doing
that and listen to me please you know
and we just sort of
do it on the telephone if you hear
someone's distracted you go hello are
you there they go sorry sorry you know
you can actually catch people
and I find that those interactions you
know I'm a Pacer I like to Pace when I'm
on the phone when I'm thinking I can't
Pace on Zoom which means my thinking is
junk right when I'm on a phone call I
can walk around I can walk around
wherever I go and I can talk to somebody
and I can be much more engaged I think
we especially for sales people
use the phone pick up the phone how are
you wanted to check in with you you know
have a conversation without Zoom uh I
actually think it's actually much better
for building relationship believe it or
not having zooms occasionally is great
too but I think we've un we've under
we've forgotten we've forgotten how good
the phone is finite mindset is
everything is about this transaction
this listing an infinite mindset is I
may win or lose this game I may win or
lose this transaction it'll be another
one and the goal is not to win this one
the goal is to be better and what
happens is you win more often see and
where I struggle with that honestly is I
want to crush it every time you're a
highly competitive A type personality I
get it but if that's all you do you're
not going to be in the game but this is
my point in the infinite game the
infinite mindset is about having the
strength the will and the resources will
is I really still enjoy this industry
and the resources I got the money to
stay in the game if you run out of will
you run out of resources you find a
different line of work right the goal is
not to win every game the goal is to
stay in the game as long as possible and
you're more likely to stay in the game
as long as possible if you're enjoying
it and if you're making money think of
those agents who are better than you
whether they're better marketers or
better sales person or they have more
recommendations and again you don't have
to like them you have to thank them and
study them and learn what they're doing
as I said because their strengths are
revealing to people revealing to your
weaknesses and sometimes partner with
them because you're actually stronger
together but hating them is stupid all
it does is make you come focus on them
rather than focus on yourself all it
does is make you focus and sit around
with your friends and be like but they
don't do this well you're not doing any
of that either you know so it puts all
your focus in all the wrong places you
know what it's like if you ski through
trees every skier knows this if you say
don't hit a treat you hit a tree because
all you're doing is looking at trees
where when you're skiing through trees
and you say follow the path you don't
hit a tree because you're only looking
at the path so your mindset is if all
you're doing is focusing on them then
you're you're hitting trees is what
you're doing you're focusing all the
things that make you weak rather than
focusing on all the things that make you
better a term that's been overused in
business this concept of authenticity
right all that authenticity means is the
things you say and the things you do you
actually believe
and there's a lot of room for cynicism
in the in the in the uh financial
advisor World
um because every financial advisor says
the right thing I'm here to help you I'm
Hillary to help you find your nest egg
to achieve your financial goals and blah
blah blah blah blah blah every financial
advisor I've ever met tells me the same
thing but then the way they make me feel
not always consistent where they may say
the right things but then they're not
actually listening to the things that I
want I can feel that they're just trying
to hammer a product
um they're not actually trying to do
what I what I ex what I talk about but
rather I can feel the feel that they
have an agenda that they're pushing
something on me and so you know we're
highly attuned social animals we can
tell the difference and if somebody's
going to put their agenda their uh uh
commission their interests first then
stop saying I'm here to help you and
achieve your financial goals because I
care about you
saying those words I don't have I don't
have a problem with somebody being
selfishly minded they approach their
business just stop pretending that
you're not
because the ones that truly do care will
be way more creative if they say I'm
truly trying to help you they'll be
offering advice and forwarding articles
that have nothing to do with with the
financial tools that you can buy from me
I might send you an article about you
know your teenagers and and screen time
for example because you because that's
one of the things you're concerned about
and I'm here to help you live a better
life like I may be more curious about
all of the aspects of about helping you
of which some are the things that I can
deliver on within Financial advice and
some Financial tools so I think I think
if you got into this business to help
people then help people
um I think that's really really
important I think one of the things that
the that the pandemic revealed quite
frankly was the weakness of so many
corporate cultures I mean we're we're
seeing the great resignation happening
and if you read articles or listen to
some of the Talking Heads you know the
prevailing thought is well they're
getting you know checks from the
government so they're not encouraged to
come back to work
um or they're pursuing their dreams you
know which which we've seen as well in
our own company somebody wants to go be
a screenwriter and even though we have a
great relationship and they love their
job they they want to pursue their
dreams but the other the other thing
that I think is is underlying that it's
that it's missing that these these
commentaries are missing is that
um the cultures uh may have been weaker
than we like to think they are
um uh that the the sense of belonging
that people have when they would come to
work is actually a lot a lot more
tenuous than we'd like to believe so the
the the bond that's allowing them to go
off and do other things is is easily
broken
um I think strong cultures when there's
a strong corporate culture we recognize
that I can pursue my dreams and work
because I love it here and I know my
team is supportive of me becoming a
screenwriter or something and I can do
both or even though I'm making money
potentially even more money
um there's so much more I get from my
work you know the camaraderie the love
the support I get all of this training
on how to be a better listener and a
better Communicator which is having me
in my marriage and helping me with my
kids and I don't want to lose that plus
I I have my I have close friends at work
um and I can speak up and say hey I'm
I'm being offered more money from the
government is there anything you can
help you know the point is it becomes a
conversation rather than a rather than a
resignation so I think one of the things
that we're missing is this might be a
wake-up call for a lot of companies that
our culture is just not as strong as we
think they are you know it's been spoken
about for years that Millennials you
know and now gen Z are just not loyal to
work they bounce around from job year to
year to year well is that them or is
that us maybe if we had stronger
cultures they wouldn't want to leave
maybe if we offered them more than
simply Financial incentives for hitting
certain numbers that they'd want to stay
maybe if they felt that they were
growing like as human beings there would
be things that were more appealing to
them than simply simply a bigger
paycheck somewhere else so I actually
think it's it's a it's a big wake-up
call frankly
um uh that that we we should go back and
look at our cultures and say are we are
we as good as we think we are we always
talk about being a stable company we
talk about investing in stable companies
and you know are you are you stable and
you think about stability stability is
is an immobile object
you know uh and and so uh companies that
are built for stability yes they're able
to weather storms but they don't come
out stronger or better they just come
out they get through
building a company for resilience means
that you go into darkness but you're
actually able to adapt for New Times new
technologies new cultures New Politics
new tastes and you come actually out of
the hard times stronger than you went in
um Victorinox is a great example
Victorinox many of us know them by their
signature product which is the old Swiss
army knife and this company made
basically made a name for themselves on
this basically one line of product and
they had other product but this was this
was the core and then something happened
that they couldn't predict nor could
they uh prepare for which is September
11th happened and overnight we were
banned from taking their product in our
bags
in our hand luggage or in our pockets we
so many of us used to carry a Swiss army
knife in our pockets or just throw one
in our hand luggage like we all had one
you know every birthday for every
teenager they got at least one right
um every corporate gift you had a couple
of Swiss Army knives and now we were
banned from carrying them which means
you're less likely to buy one to give as
a gift and so their business their
business plummeted overnight
through no fault of their own through no
market conditions nothing predictable
but the genius of Victorinox is that
they were built for resilience and what
they did was they in good times instead
of giving away all the money and big
bonuses in good times they actually
saved a ton of money and their attitude
was
um good times don't last but neither do
bad times and if we want to get through
bad times we need to have we need we
need cash and so instead of panicking
and taking loans or whatever it is they
had their own stack of cash that it that
they'd been hoarding so they had a
little Financial resilience but then
they um looked to other products and
they asked their people to help build up
and they started investing heavily in
watches now we have Victorinox watches
which are much more and it's still Swiss
made everything that they could do
everything that they knew how to do
clothing everything they leveraged their
brand heavily and they built it back up
also they protected all of their people
they actually made deals with companies
prior that if bad times ever happened
that that other companies would borrow
their employees which I thought was
genius so they didn't lose their jobs
they just did their job somewhere else
and they completely reinvented their
company company now to this day their
Swiss army knife never really recovered
it came up back a bit but it's now not
the major product as a minor product
that they sell because they actually
came out stronger and reinvented and to
be able to do that think about that
coming in as one kind of company and
coming out of another kind of company
very very rare and very very special but
very infinite minded I think some people
turn off the humanity when they go to
work
um you know they they they may be you
know loving parents and loving friends
and loving you know children to their
own parents and yet for some reason
there's a switch that they think that
that's irresponsible to do at work now
I'm not talking about necessarily
wearing your heart on your sleeve every
day there is something called emotional
professionalism you know if you're
having a bad day you can say listen I'm
a little off my game today but you can't
sit in a meeting with your arms folded
and be grumpy and give one word answers
that's that's emotionally unprofessional
you know you can have hard feelings but
you can't go around screaming and
yelling at people you know you can
um so I think there's a there's
emotional professionalism but I think
for some reason especially as people
make their way up the ranks
um they think that expressing any kind
of emotion is a sign of weakness
um even that word vulnerability we talk
you know it's such a common word now
being talked about in in the business
world that you have to be vulnerable to
this day it makes some people feel very
uncomfortable I don't want to be
vulnerable well all vulnerability means
um is saying things like I don't know or
I need help or I'm overwhelmed or can
you you know can you help me do this
because I don't know how to do this or
I've been promoted to a position where
maybe I need more training and the
reason we're afraid of saying that is
for fear that it makes us look weak
which will then damage our careers the
reality is the total opposite by saying
I don't know means someone can help us
but instead we choose to lie hide and
fake very often which eventually gets
revealed enough stress piled on on that
lying hiding and faking collapses either
professionally or personally either we
either feel the stress or or the
projects that we're working on start to
go haywire and very often when we get to
those points everybody knows anyway
um and uh the amazing thing that I've
learned is when you say can somebody
help me
um we're surrounded by people who would
love to help us they just didn't think
we needed it because we acted as if we
didn't so I think a large part of it is
is quite frankly fear fear that if I
express these things that'll that people
will think I'm not qualified for my job
um uh where the the uh the the the
opposite is true and remember when you
are in a position of leadership you
don't actually have to be better at
doing the job that the people you lead
you have to be responsible for taking
care of them to make sure they're good
at their job but for some reason we
think that
um I have to be better than you at your
own job because I'm the leader
completely false I just have to make
sure that you're equipped you have the
tools the training and the psychological
safety to come to be the best you can be
even if it's better than me one of the
things that um we we do is um is is we
is creating a culture in which people
understand that the reason we're giving
feedback is not to quote unquote
criticize them but to help them grow as
human beings and that has to be that has
to be established like this this is what
we're gonna the advice I I offer is it's
not just a checklist that you do and
everything goes fine you know you create
a culture in which uh difficult
conversations and uh and and critical
feedback are welcomed or at least
understood
um but it's also how we give it um
usually we give it by pulling out a
piece of paper and pointing out the
thing that's wrong
um and you know and saying you've got to
fix something right we usually point to
the evidence first
um as opposed to starting by with by by
the human being which is you know
there's stuff I want to share with you I
don't know where what it means but I
wanted to raise it with you in case
there is an issue
um because I care about you and I want
to see that you grow here but there's
some evidence that things are going a
little sideways and I want to I want to
address them with them to see what
opportunities there are or if there's
anything wrong because I don't know the
reasons behind it but
um here's what for example the way you
talked to your teammates the other day
was a little harsh and ordinarily I'd be
one to say oh you know you're having a
bad day it's no problem you know
everybody gets a everybody gets a bad
day but you've been really beating up on
people
um I don't even know if you're aware of
that right
um and sometimes they'll say I'm having
a hard time and it opens up or they'll
say I wasn't even aware I didn't even
know or it reveals something as opposed
to saying stop yelling at people nobody
wants to work for you if all you do is
yell at people you know it's hard for
people to receive and so good feedback
is not just about conveying the point
we're trying to make it's about creating
a condition in which the person is more
likely to listen and hear it so we're
all proud of ourselves once we've told
them we did you did you give her the
feedback yeah I told her right did they
hear the feedback uh different question
I think one of the essential
skills of being a good coach is
listening and this is a skill that is
not taught in school we don't learn it
on Home unfortunately and and we don't
learn it at work
listening is not hearing the words that
are spoken that's like my favorite quote
that you say go ahead I'm sorry
listening is
I thought I was being original
the the listening listening is not about
hearing the words that are spoken it's
not being able to Parrot back what
somebody said to you listening is
listening for meaning right
um you uh uh um you are a good listener
the test for being good a listener is if
the other person feels heard
right I'll say that again right write
that down so so I mean we've all had we
just take it out of the context of
business right we've all had an argument
or wanted to share our feelings with a
friend or a loved one right spouse
girlfriend boyfriend you're sitting on
the couch and you say something's
bugging you and you say can I just tell
you something that's bugging me and they
respond by trying to fix it or they
respond by pointing out the facts that
may or may not align with how you feel
right well that's impossible because
this is what happened and what they're
missing is you are not looking for them
you're not looking for them to compare
the facts of what's being said you just
want to feel heard you just want
somebody to go oh my God that's really
hard yeah I hear it I hear that thank
you for sharing that with me that must
be difficult
I need it right I'll give you a a a a a
very funny example of bad listening so I
used to date a girl who's an air traffic
controller air attractive controllers
are breed into themselves and it's only
about the facts and I woke up one
morning I had something in my eye and I
couldn't open my eye it was hurting and
I'm like flushing it out with water and
nothing's work and I mean I couldn't
even open my eyes have her come on like
come here come here I'm gonna look in my
eye what did you see anything do you
understand anything and she looks in she
goes like this and she goes there's
nothing there and then walks away
and I eventually you know whatever it
was I eventually was okay and I went up
to her I was like
WTF right
I'm like I had something in my eye you
just walked away
and she's like there was nothing there
so what do you want me to do
I was like a little sympathy she's like
well that's not going to get anything
out of your eye
listening is standing by my side while
I'm flushing it out with water and go oh
my God that must hurt so much yeah it
does thank you right that's listening
and if somebody can learn to listen and
now now this is where it gets actionable
this is not me just waxing philosophical
and telling funny stories about
listening my friend will gudero do how
many of you are
or restaurant people have you ever heard
of 11 Madison Park so at some point in
New York City 11 Madison Park was the
best rest restaurant in the world right
ranked number one and will believes in
this he's he was the former owner he
believes in this concept of unreasonable
Hospitality which is going to what good
services and then going way way way
Beyond and one of the core tenets of
unreasonable hospitality is learning to
listen and I'll give you an example that
directly impacts your business most
agents don't listen
and I'll give you an example what do you
do what do you do for your clients after
they close on a home right it's very
common we've all we've we've all bought
a home too right which is you walk into
this new home that you just bought as a
buyer and there's a bottle of champagne
in the fridge
there's a basket of flowers on the
dining room table
the same basket of flowers that you gave
to every other client the same bottle of
champagne that you gave to every client
generic I'm a number it's just it's just
rote but if you were listening
while they were looking at all those
homes and they saw this one little room
that was too small to make a bedroom it
was just sort of a stupid little Nook
that nobody really understood why that
room existed in the house and your
client walked in and goes I could make
this my yoga room and that's the house
they bought instead of putting a bottle
of champagne in the house this is what
will talks about instead of putting a
bottle of champagne in the fridge why
not put a yoga mat in that room
with a little note that says it's
perfect right
that's called listening and every single
time you go out
every single time you go out with
clients
uh they are telling you things they're
telling you stories they're waxing
philosophical they're telling you what
they don't like and what they do like
the problem is you're listening to
whether they like big Windows you're
listening to whether they like the view
you're listening to whether they have
two cars and they need three cars or
whatever it is but you're not listening
to the reasons why the why you're not
listening for the meaning and that's
those are the little notes you want to
make that make someone feel seen and
make someone feel heard I had the
opportunity to work with the Navy Seals
and within the Navy Seals there's
actually a more Elite group within the
series that's much harder to get into
you have to be a sealed for like five
years before you even can get into this
even more Elite group and I asked the
director of training for this group you
know how do you choose who gets into
this more Elite group within your own
within your own culture and he drew uh
an XY access he drew a graph for me
um uh and on the vertical axis you wrote
performance and on the horizontal axis
he wrote trust the way they Define
performance is how good are you at your
job right your skill set uh the way they
Define trust is what kind of person are
you and the way they put it is I may
trust you with my money I mean trust you
with my life but do I trust you with my
money and my wife's right so
so uh clearly nobody wants a low
performer of low trust clearly clearly
everybody wants the high performer of
high trust in their team clearly they
learned is that a high performer of low
trust is actually a toxic team member
and they would rather have a medium
performer of high trust sometimes a low
performer pie trust it's a relative
scale over the high performer of low
trust and this is one of the highest
performing organizations on the planet
and they put huge uh Credence in the
trustworthiness and the character of the
team member over their simple uh
performance metrics in business we're
the opposite we have a million metrics
to measure someone's performance and we
have negligible to no metrics to measure
someone's trust and so you may have a
selfish driven toxic team member who if
they're high performing what do we do we
promote them and sometimes you get to
the point where leadership knows that
this person is toxic and you say you
know you probably shouldn't do something
about this you maybe want to remove them
from the team and they say the same
thing they're like yeah I know but the
performance is so good
you're literally just waiting for
something to collapse meaning either
other people will leave or the culture
will start to crack or there's a scandal
or that person will leave because they
get a better job of them they're not
loyal so they may be your highest
performer but they're not loyal
um with the what the seals learn is uh
is sometimes these these medium
performance of high trestles are your
best natural uh uh best natural leaders
the irony is you know you go to any team
it's actually really easy to find these
toxic team members that's the irony even
though we don't formally measure it go
to any team and ask them who the
is and they'll all point to the same
person okay
um uh and and and and that that's an
opportunity to coach that I don't
believe in firing them I believe in
coaching them you let people go when
they proved to be uncoachable and by the
way if you go to that same team you say
who do you trust more than anybody else
who's got your back no matter what who's
always who's always there to help you
they're probably also point to the same
person who might be your best natural
leader and they may not be your best
individual performer we don't teach
difficult conversations we don't uh
teach conflict resolution we don't teach
uh de-escalation uh and we don't teach
how to give and receive feedback we
don't teach how to treat ideas we don't
even teach people how to have a meeting
like we don't teach any of these things
and so we're just leaving it up to
chance to hope that somebody knows what
they're doing which we would never let
somebody on the front line do we give
them tons of training on how to do their
jobs so part of it is is is the skill
set that we that we can train
um the other thing is a lot of leaders I
think are afraid of doing things for
fear of saying the wrong thing and again
this this really lends itself to the
training we need to give our leaders and
especially I think this was really
exaggerated after the murder of George
Floyd
um where so many leaders did nothing
um they're not bad people uh they were
just so afraid of saying the wrong thing
or inflaming a situation or triggering
someone that they chose to to just do
nothing
um and so one of the things we need to
do is teach people how to lean into
tension
um uh and and to learn how to
de-escalate one's own anger or or one's
own trigger and again you brought it up
before which is and replace it with
curiosity tell me more what else I'm
struggling to under stand let me tell
you the story that's going through my
head I think is a really big one that
I've learned which is because I'm
reacting based on my own narrative right
and so they're reacting to my words or
my reaction and so one of the things
that's really helped me is to share
what's going on in my head so that
people have the context of where my
reaction is coming from let me let me
tell you what my history is and what my
background is I'm not saying this is
right or wrong I'm just telling you my
story and I'll say I had this happen in
the past where X Y and Z and so I'm
nervous at your suggestion because in
the past this has happened can you help
me resolve this or do you understand
where I'm coming from
and I think the more we can share what's
going on in the process rather than
simply you know responding with our
answers or our reactions helps the other
person see the way we're trying to see
it and it also encourages us to see the
way they're trying to see it so I think
the more we share it's that
vulnerability word again right let me
tell you my history let me tell you my
baggage let me tell you my background
let me tell you my experiences let me
tell you where my opinion is coming from
um the worst thing the one that drives
me up the wall the one that triggers me
is this is how we've always done it well
why do we do it that way because this is
how we've always done it and my rule is
if you cannot tell me why we're doing it
this way that means it's it's on the
chopping block that doesn't mean it has
to change but but I want to I want real
explanations of why we do something this
way if somebody can't tell me then then
it's it's open to being changed I try
and read uh news from both sides of the
political aisle uh not to find the one I
agree with but I want to understand how
it's being reported I want to know the
different narratives that are being told
so that I can understand those
narratives so I can speak to those
narratives I can learn those narratives
and find hypocrisy in both sides by the
way
um I think that the one the one mistake
that we all fall into is to decide that
the ones that I agree with are right and
the ones that I disagree with are wrong
um and this this binary notion of right
versus wrong
um is is what's gotten us into this into
this mess in the first place
um life is not so so so so so black and
white in no respect uh it's nuanced and
gray and complicated and messy and to to
understand that we are hypocrites in our
own opinions
um and so is the other side and simply
pointing out the hypocrisy of the other
side is of no help whatsoever what's
more important is important that our own
hypocrisy
um and to try and understand that like I
said it's a worthy rivalry thing right
it's not trying to dominate or be right
but it's rather tried to improve and to
grow
um and and so one of the things that I
default to our values
um I'm very proud of the fact that some
of my friendships are with people who
have very very very different uh
political points of view
um who we voted very very differently in
political elections
um and we can go to blows uh talking
about some of the things that the
government is is deciding whether we
agree or disagree with it
um but at the end of the day their
values are like mine and we and we
believe in taking care of each other and
we believe in looking out for each other
and at the end of the day more than
their politics they're my friend and I
learned this lesson the hard way where I
was walking I was going for a walk with
a friend who has very different
political views than me
um and she said something and I I
definitely thought it and I fear I may
have said it how can you be so stupid
and I realized I just called my friend
stupid and she completely got angry at
me not because I disagreed with her it's
because I judged her and insulted her
and she you know what she was a hundred
percent right
and what I had to learn in that moment
was to listen
was to replace my judgment with
curiosity and to understand where her
point of view comes from and that I and
that the more Curious I became to
understand that there were actually
things that we did agree upon and though
we may not have agreed upon everything
we actually could find common ground and
that Common Ground always boiled down to
our values and the more that I got good
at listening to her she actually we
became much more open to listening to me
and so as opposed to me hammering my
opinion at her we started to have
conversations and so I think when you go
to a values level politics becomes
secondary but when we let go of our
values then all we have is the politics
which is upsetting you cannot have
Innovation or progress without failure
it doesn't exist and if you truly aren't
failing as you're trying to innovate
then you're probably not pushing very
hard because you haven't broken anything
you're making very very safe choices we
could never put a person on the moon
without a bunch of rockets blowing up
first like I met a CFO once I asked him
the priorities of the company and he
said efficiency and Innovation and I
laughed and said well good luck with
that you know Innovation is inherently
inefficient because it requires
experimentation the experimentation
requires failure much is said about fail
fast I actually don't like the term
failure the problem with the word
failure is it's like the word cancer
it's too broad like if you have stage
four liver cancer or you have a mild
melanoma those things are both cold
cancer but they are clearly not the same
thing and the same thing is when we hear
the word failure some people think
failure means experimentation but a lot
of people think failure means
catastrophe and so when we tell our
company failure is good fail fast that
literally scares me we don't want to
fail so I think we need a new word we
want to avoid failure failure is
catastrophic and it should be avoided
but Falling I think we should encourage
when a kid falls off a bicycle we didn't
tell them they fail we tell them they
fail and what do we tell them get back
up and try again so I don't want to tell
people they fail I want to see people
they fail and I want to encourage them
to try again and brush up their needs so
I think we should fall and fall often
and I will judge the quality of
innovation not necessarily by if you
fell but how quickly you can put
yourself back up and try again let's
reinforce that point because I think
it's an important one that fulfillment
is a right and not a privilege and when
we go out with our friends for dinner
when we used to be able to do that
um uh uh you know you sit around and
somebody says I love my job and
everybody goes oh my God you're so lucky
like they won something that statement
should be the norm not the exception we
should all get to go to dinner and say I
love my job and it's the one person who
says I don't that's that that we can
that we can intervene
um so yeah I believe it is a right and
we have a responsibility ourselves to to
find a place where we want to work with
the people that we would work with
rather than just taking the biggest
salary
that we have a responsibility to take
care of the people around us and we have
a responsibility to speak up and ask our
our leaders to work with us and create a
place where people want to come to work
where we where there's a safe space for
us to take care of each other and feel
taken care of so there's Mutual
responsibility all around
so when you say you know how do we do it
well it's it requires constant work it's
like how do you stay healthy well I can
give you a whole list of things you have
to do you have to eat right you have to
nurse your personal relationships you
have to get enough sleep you have to
exercise you have to meditate you have
to be mindful you know there's a little
there's like 30 things and you can't do
all those things well all the time it's
a striving
um and uh and when one's doing well
sometimes one one thing falls off it's a
striving and it's the same the the
pursuit of fulfillment is a striving you
know I I think it's you know this is why
I make the distinction between
fulfillment and happiness you know to
seek happiness is a lot easier because
happiness is fleeting you know you you
you get a new job you're happy you get a
raise you're happy you win a new piece
of business you're happy you're given a
gift you're happy you know somebody says
something nice to you you're happy and
that feeling goes away
no nobody nobody walks around with a
sense of happiness for a job they got
four years ago it's gone
um where fulfillment is different
fulfillment you can feel fulfilled by
your work even if you're not enjoying it
today
you can feel fulfilled by your work even
if you if you're having a bad a bad day
you know or or one of your colleagues is
grumpy you can still be fulfilled by the
work it's more it's more uh it's it's
more infinite it's more constant and so
um whereas happiness is you know the
things that lead up to it it sounds more
like an event fulfillment is a striving
it's a lifestyle and you do all these
things like having a just cause like
building trusting teams and working to
be the leader you wish you had in other
words you see your life as a life of
service to those around you whether
you're in a company whether you're an
employee whether you're a leader or if
you're just a parent that you see your
life in service you know to your spouse
your partner or your and your kids and
indeed your community what makes a
community highly functional is that we
view uh that every single person within
that Community sees their responsibility
to serve the community rather than
standing around demanding the community
does something for them I think courage
is external right the reason someone has
courage to jump out of an airplane is
because there's a parachute on their
back it's the external thing a a a a a
world famous trapeze artist would never
try a brand new death-defying act for
the first time without a net it's the
net that gives them the courage
you know the Navy Seals are considered
one of the highest performing
organizations on the planet and a former
seal was asked what kind of person makes
it into the seals
and he said I can't tell you the kind of
person that makes it in but I can tell
you the kind of person that doesn't make
it it he said the Star College athletes
who have never really been tested to the
core of their being
none of them make it in
he said the preening leaders who like to
delegate everything
none of them make it in
he says the guys who show up with
hulking muscles covered in tattoos
because they want to show you how tough
they are
none of them make it in
he sent it he said some of the guys who
make it in are skinny and scrawny he
said some of the guys who make it in you
see them shivering out of fear
he said but every single one of the guys
who makes it in when they're emotionally
exhausted when they're physically
exhausted when they have absolutely
nothing left to give
somehow some way they're able to dig
down deep inside themselves to find the
energy to help the guy next them
in other words the reason these
organizations and these people have the
courage to do remarkable things is not
because of their internal strength it's
because they have the absolute
confidence that there is someone to the
left of them and someone to the right of
them that cares about them
and they will know that and it's the
quality of the relationships that we
maintain professionally and personally
that give us the courage to do difficult
things
Isaac Stern the famous violinist said
music is what happens between the notes
well something like trust happens
between the meetings you know we few
people think about the importance of
building trust when they go to work or
the what I need to do today to build
trust with somebody like this doesn't
really go through people's minds but we
have Chit Chat as we walk into the
meeting we've Chit Chat when we walk out
of the meeting and we see somebody the
whole they're like oh meant to tell you
something or you knock on someone's door
and be like got a minute and all those
little innocuous interactions over the
course of time like any relationship
build trust it's about setting up the
computer and setting up zoom and having
a work session with somebody you know
like we're not working on the same thing
but I want to work with somebody a work
buddy or having a lunch with somebody
over Zoom or a Monday morning huddle
where we talk about what's on our heart
and minds but we do not talk business on
purpose or Friday uh cocktails that are
just voluntary but the most important
one is to just pick up the phone and
call people and say hey how are you
that level of empathy just check in on
someone and I think we neglect it
because we get mired in the day-to-day
but you know one of you know if you're
organized or disorganized you know
literally keep a list of your team on a
little card next to your computer and
just you know go through it and have I
called this person a while and talk to
this but I'm just going to call and
check in it doesn't matter if
something's wrong or not wrong just
check in on them you know don't wait for
something to Break
um and let people know that they're uh
that there's connection and there's a
way to reach out and say I need help
um because if if if and and the most
important thing is for leaders to be
honest and open about their need to ask
for help
and that that'll work they happen to
have a coffee bar uh in the lobby of the
Four Seasons in Vegas and so one
afternoon I went and bought myself a cup
of coffee and uh the Barista working
that day was a kid named Noah
Noah was funny and charming and engaging
and I spent far too long buying a cup of
coffee because I just so enjoyed talking
to Noah so as is my nature I asked Noah
um do you like your job
and without skipping a beat Noah said I
love my job now in my line of work
that's significant like is rational I
like the people I like the I like the
work you know I get paid well I like my
job love is emotional it's a higher
order connection right like do you love
your wife I like her a lot right clearly
it's clearly a different standard right
so when Noah said I love my job my ears
perked up this kid has an emotional
connection to his work so immediately I
followed up and said tell me
specifically what the Four Seasons is
doing that you would say to me you love
your job
and again without skipping a beat Noah
said throughout the day managers will
walk past me and ask me how I'm doing
ask me if there's anything that I need
to do my job better not just my manager
any manager and then he said I also work
at another hotel
and there the managers walked past us
and catch us when we do something wrong
they're the managers are always trying
to drive performance and make sure we
hit our numbers he said there I'd like
to keep my head below the radar get
through the day and just collect my
paycheck only at the Four Seasons do I
feel I can be myself
now this is the exact same human being
working at two different companies and
yet our experience of him will be
profoundly different not because of him
but because of the leadership
environment in which he works
you know I get this question all the
time you know Simon how do we get the
most out of our people people are not a
towel that you ring them out to see how
much you can get out of them
you know it's it's a it's it's it's it's
that's a good one man
[Applause]
[Music]
it's a flawed question the question is
how do we create an environment on in
which our people can work at their
natural best and that is the art of
leadership it's creating environment in
which relationships can thrive in which
trust can Thrive and we all know what it
feels like to be on a trusting team
right
um it means that we feel psychologically
safe enough
to raise our hand and say
um I made a mistake
or I need help
or I'm having trouble at home and it's
affecting my work
or I'm scared or I don't know what to do
um without any fear of humiliation or
retribution but rather to say these
things with the absolute confidence that
someone on our team will rush to support
us unfortunately we also all know what
it feels like not to work on a trusting
team where admitting any of those things
could hurt your chances of promotion
could hurt your chances of it you could
be humiliated
and so when we when we work on teams
where leadership is creating an
environment where there's where trust is
a at a premium
um we force our people to come to work
and lie hide and fake where they're
pretending that they've made no mistakes
they're lying hiding and faking and
eventually things will crack and things
will eventually break and and when you
talk about reinvention and you talk
about Innovation and you talk about
challenging the status quo or whatever
it is
necessarily there's risk and necessarily
there are mistakes and necessarily
there's stupid ideas and you have to
create an environment which that's good
the alternative is everybody playing it
safe which is not the way that leads to
to best or significant Improvement
there's no such thing as a perfect job
and there's no such thing as a perfect
person of course there are things that
we are doing that hold ourselves back
and of course there are things about the
environment in which we work whether
it's the people or the job or the
whatever the circumstances that may also
be holding us back I mean but to see
ourselves as victims is not is not the
up is not the thing
um but rather to seek opportunity and it
goes back to that growth mindset
um uh which is it's what I've learned is
one of the best ways to grow oneself is
to actually help somebody on the team
grow service you know there's an entire
section in the book shop called
self-help and there's no section of the
Bookshop called help others and I think
what we've done is we've over indexed on
the whole rugged individualism sort of
self-helpy thing how can I be successful
how can I grow my business how can I
lose weight how can I find love and yet
we forget how can I help somebody else
grow their business how can I help
somebody else find success how can I
help help somebody else lose weight and
find love
Etc and the irony is is the more that we
set out to help somebody else because we
have more objectivity with other people
ironically we actually learn to help
ourselves I I tried this out I did a
little experiment
a dear friend of mine was going through
a hard a hard time
a solopreneur
um
the work wasn't going well her marriage
was shaky and she was in a bad place
and so she knows what I do for a living
so she called me up and says would you
spend some time with me I said of course
so every single week religiously we
spent about 90 minutes together she'd
come over and we would talk and I would
offer some
perspective and some ideas and she'd
feel great for like a day or two and
then she'd go back and we'd get together
the next week and she'd feel great for a
couple of days and then go back in this
repeating pattern went on for quite a
while
and then I remember my own work which is
the idea of service
and had a little idea which is to switch
to switch it around and I called her up
and said look I would like some coaching
too and it was genuine I said you know
me better than anybody else I trust you
completely when we get together for one
of our sessions Can it can I can I use
up some of the time can I tell you what
I'm going through
and what ended up happening is we spent
all 90 minutes talking about my stuff
and this went week after week after week
where she was just the uh advice giver
and strange things started to happen she
started to get more stability in her
work more stability to her marriage her
confidence went up and it was because
she was helping me that she was gaining
all the insights and perspective because
it wasn't personalized it's like sales
training and anybody who's ever gone
through sales training you know this
which is you always do it with three
people you know the person who plays the
role of the salesperson the person who
plays the role of the uh the person
you're selling to the buyer and and an
observer and it's the Observer that does
the learning not the people playing the
roles well in this case you got to see
herself not being not be so close to it
gave her objectivity so I'm a great
believer in if you have a problem to
solve it work try and help somebody else
solve that same problem there's another
guy who does what I do he writes books
he gives talks Etc his work is extremely
well respected and and I admire his work
as well I happen to hate him
um
he's never he's never done anything mean
to me and we've always had a very
quality relationship when we see each
other professionally I have an arbitrary
hatred of him
and as a result of my hatred
um I'm extremely competitive with him
um I would log on to Amazon on a regular
basis no and check my book rankings and
then immediately check his
and keep in mind I check no one else's
Just the Two of Us and if he was ahead I
was angry and if I was ahead I was smug
and whenever his name came up in polite
conversation I would see underneath we
were invited to speak together at a
conference where we would be interviewed
together and I don't mean like like
literally we would be on the stage
together and the interviewer thought it
would be fun if we introduced each other
um
um and so I went first
and I turned to him and I said
um you make me really insecure
and I said all of your strengths are all
of my weaknesses and whenever your name
comes up I get really uncomfortable
and he looked at me and he said funny I
think the same thing about you
the reason I was so competitive with him
had nothing to do with him it had
everything to do with me because his
weaknesses revealed to me because his
strength revealed to me my weaknesses
it's more difficult to take a hard look
at myself and say Here's all the work
you have to do it's much easier and dare
I say more fun to to direct all my
energies at beating him
um that turned out to be an extremely
cathartic experience
and I learned the value of a worthy
rival
and the funny thing is after that
experience I've never checked mine or
his book wrecking since
um I applaud his work celebrate him want
him to do well because it turns out
working together
we actually are stronger
and I think this is the same Folly in
business right I I like you know which
is we decide who our competitors are
and then we obsess with beating them
like ABC NBC CBS and fox were obsessed
with beating each other and all they did
was look at Nielsen radiations every
morning
and then Netflix came up and didn't like
who cares they're all the reminders
because they weren't even looking they
weren't even watching
because that's the arbitrariness of if
you I remember back in the early days
when I first started my career I was in
the ad business and I was Junior dog's
buddy to the junior dog's body and
um I was on the
um competitive analysis team and
basically what that meant was we studied
the competition and we put together
decks to the executives of look what the
competition is doing
and
we sometimes would hire outside
Consultants to run you know research for
us and if it was too expensive to study
seven of them we'd cut it down to four
which is hilarious if you think about it
so you're making decisions based on four
and ignore anyway you get my point so um
I think the value of the other players
in your industry of the other players in
the game is not to beat them because
there's no such thing as I said before
you know Best Buy didn't win anything
when Circuit City went bankrupt
um but it's to recognize and respect
them there are some players
who do some or many things better than
you maybe they have a better leadership
stronger culture better marketing maybe
their products are better designed who
knows what and instead of trying to beat
them which couldn't mean you choose
underhanded things or just drop your
price
you actually say okay let's make our
product even better they have revealed
our weakness let's Now work on that
because the ultimate the only competitor
in an infinite game is yourself a just
cause is something a lot more idealistic
it's a statement of the world that you
wish that the the way the world what you
wished it worked the the world that you
imagine like we imagine a world that's
PWC we imagine a world in which
and then we devote our practice we
devote our energy we devote our
resources to advance towards that cause
and we're going to bring our clients
with us the work that we do takes us
closer to that quote so I'll give you an
example so my just cause our
organizations just cause we imagine a
world so you can see there's that
Forward Thinking which as an aside which
is why we call it vision is because you
have to be able to see it right so we
imagine a world in which the vast
majority of people wake up every single
morning inspired
feel safe wherever they are and end the
day fulfilled by the work that they do
that is our cause that is a cause so
just that we would be willing to
sacrifice in order to advance closer
towards that ideal we will never get
there it is an ideal okay and and you
can look at organizations or leaders
that have made profound impact in their
Industries or in the world you'll see
these just causes whether it's all men
are created equal right it's a just
cause imperfect in all in its own way
but you can see a nation striving
um I have a dream literally imagining
that one day little black children will
hold hands on the playground with little
white children imperfect in its own uh
in in reality but you can see a nation
striving
um when Apple and Steve Jobs used to
talk about empowering individuals to
stand up to Big Brother you can see the
attraction to the personal computer
because it literally gives power to an
individual to compete against a
corporation imperfect but a striving and
all of these things become striving that
become incredibly inspiring for for a
Workforce because they feel like they're
contributing to something bigger than
themselves but when you think about
innovation
if you say provide greater value for our
clients
and it's not wrong I have to stress it's
not wrong
but but
when you say innovate around that The
Innovation tends to be more features and
benefits it tends to be tweaking and
efficiencies when you say be the best I
don't even know how you innovate around
that right you can't say some to say
somebody
you know make innovate so we're better
but when you say Innovative way to
advance this the ideas can come from
anywhere inside the organization and the
ideas tend to be a lot bigger okay so
it's not that those things are wrong
that what I'm what I'm offering are what
a a clearer path to embracing an
infinite mindset okay right it's not
that the other doesn't work it doesn't
have value it just has less value in the
infinite game I was uh during covid
um I worked out with a friend of mine
who lives somewhere else we worked out
on face time together we would just turn
on FaceTime and just do the same workout
together basically and one day we were
doing a particularly difficult workout
and I said to her I have some good news
and I have some bad news she says well
what's the bad news I said the bad news
is we're only halfway done she says well
what's the good news I said the good
news is we're already halfway done
and that simple the simple way in which
I present the information literally
profoundly changes the way in which we
do the second half of the the workout
we're only halfway done the rest of the
the workout's a slog it's difficult it's
hard and we don't want to do it we're
already halfway done I mean it's all
downhill we've already done this once we
can easily finish this off and it's
amazing how easy it is to change our
mindset
um uh uh and so it's the same thing here
um we've done it in our own organization
where um we see another organization who
you know I mean I hate to use the word I
use it just for the for the example but
outpaces us I mean we don't care about
that but and and instead of getting all
angry and often bothered and trying to
beat them we say to them we're the
arrival what what you know what strength
do they have that's revealing a weakness
in us and we're like oh my goodness our
website sucks or our e-commerce sucks or
our you know customer service sucks or
whatever it is you know we spend a lot
of time looking at people who we admire
who are in our space who do some or many
things better than us we like look at
their websites we look at their product
we look at the ease of use we're like
wow that's really good you know we don't
have to like it we don't have to agree
with it but we can still complement it
um and I think that's the big thing
people think that you know that you you
know uh that you have to hate everything
that somebody does nonsense you don't
have to agree or like but you do have to
respect
um and uh and quite frankly to put on
blinders and go through the world with
blinders on that there's no one else out
there and they definitely can't do
anything better than you is quite
frankly just stupid because it's just
not true
um you're not great at everything and
you never will be it's an infinite game
it's a game of constant Improvement just
like every person there's no such thing
as a perfect person you know we should
be in a growth mindset constantly trying
to improve every day of Our Lives it's
the same thing and it's even that's
difficult even that's you even that you
can't you can't grow every day even
that's hard you know it's messy and
human and that's the fun and that's why
you go back to trusting teams and why
the teamwork matters so much because
sometimes we can beat up ourselves or
get stuck in a negative mindset and all
you need is one person to walk over and
be like hey worthy rival right
so the nice thing about worthy Rivals is
it's subjective you can choose whichever
person whichever company you want you
don't have internal competition but you
can have internal internal Rivals you
know where there are other people that
you compare yourselves to and you're
trying to get better
um uh but you don't want to stab each
other in the back get angry when
somebody else gets a promotion like
we've all had that we've all had that
you know deep down inside we see when
somebody gets a promotion when we didn't
right
um even if we weren't even up for it
um uh that's that's a that's a sign
where necessary change needs to happen
uh in our mindset uh it's easier to do
than you think and when you get in the
habit of it it's absolutely wonderful
tell someone I need help like I think it
is one of us it's one of these skills
that is becoming fast lost especially
amongst a younger generation which is
the skill to ask for help you know we're
all trying to act so tough you know this
this nation over indexed on the whole
rugged individualism thing you know
um where we define success as visual
success
and and most of our metrics most of our
incentives and almost every job are
individual incentives there you know
there's no team bonus there's an
individual bonus if you hit your numbers
you know
um and uh I think we've we've overdid it
quite frankly uh and I think it's the
pendulum needs to come back uh and and
and we have to remember that we're a
team we're members of teams we're
members of families remember communities
or members of societies and this is
where maslov got it wrong you know
Maslow's hierarchy of needs he says you
know fundamentally at the bottom of the
pyramid is food and shelter
um and he put you know third you know
third up the rung he put a a uh
relationships well I've never heard of
anyone Dying by suicide because they
were hungry I've heard of people dying
by suicide because they were lonely so
in other words it can't be right and at
the top you have self-actualization how
or like I'm all self-actualized looking
down at the rest of you who aren't at
the top of the period what about shared
actualization you know and the mistake
he made is that there's a paradox which
is every moment of every day we are both
individuals and members of groups and
every day we have to reconcile that do I
put myself first at the expense of
someone else or do I prioritize someone
else at the expense of myself
and the answer is you're right you're
wrong and there's a whole group of
people that says no no you always take
care of yourself first because if you're
not healthy you can't help others and
there's another group of people says no
you always help others first because
unless you help them they won't be there
for you it's a paradox it doesn't work
it's not so clean
um and this is what we have to reconcile
every day
um and this is why finding balance and
managing it and the stresses and trains
but the the challenge of asking for help
and relying on our community really
really matters my my definition of faith
is that knowing you're on a team even
when you don't know who all the players
are
we are surrounded by people who love us
and will take care of us you just have
to ask sometimes because sometimes they
don't know that we need it there are so
many lessons that we've learned over the
past year and a half to two years that I
think prepare us to be ready for the
next future
um I got a kick out of during the height
of kovid uh the number of pundits who
said during these unpredictable times I
would smile and say all times are
unpredictable there's never been a time
that was predictable ever
um all that happened was something that
we didn't expect happened that reminded
us that our lives and our work is
unpredictable and to Future proof
ourselves means being ready for the
unpredictable
um there's something called an infinite
mindset and those with an infinite
mindset Embrace surprise they find
opportunity in the unexpected that when
something goes Haywire they go oh what
could we do with this versus a finite
mindset which likes to exert control and
keep things very very close and time
frame short because they fear the
uncertain they fear anything that's off
the plan and one of the things that we
have to do to Pro to Future proof
ourselves is to embrace things that are
surprises and embrace the opportunity in
uncertainty the other thing that I think
we have to learn on how to Future proof
ourselves is how to deal with stress and
how to deal with trauma
um uh whether somebody did well during
covid business this wise or whether they
struggle business-wise all of us all of
us suffered some sort of trauma and when
I when covet first showed up I called a
friend of mine who's active duty
military and I asked him during when
you're in combat what do you do to
compartmentalize your emotions so you
can stay Mission focused my business
blew up in right in front of me and I
had to focus on my mission of rebuilding
my business I wanted to know how to
control my emotions so I could get the
work done that I had to get done and he
gave me a very sobering warning he said
no one can compartmentalize their
emotions he says we can do it for a
short period of time but everyone will
suffer the trauma of combat sometimes
many months after we get home and he
said you will go through it
maybe not now but you will go through it
and uh sure sure enough about four or
five months in
um I started to feel extremely off my
game
um and uh I called him up and I said can
I just ask you you know uh what are your
symptoms when you go through the the the
trauma of combat I asked no leading
questions I simply said what are your
symptoms he said well one I fall out of
my sleep pattern for some reason I go to
bed late for no reason and I don't want
to get up in the morning and I thought
to myself
yep and he said I become unproductive
and I rationalize it like oh you've been
working hard it's okay if you have an
unproductive day or two but then I have
another and another and another and I
thought to myself yep
and he said I also become extremely
anti-social I don't want to talk to
anyone I definitely don't want to ask
for help
uh and I thought to myself yup
and I realized I was going through
depression I was afraid to use that word
for fear that it sounded like a
diagnosis but it was Little D depression
that's exactly what I was going through
which is why things weren't working and
so I asked my friend again so how do you
overcome it he said one you have to
force yourself to get back into your
sleep pattern and two you have to force
yourself to ask people for help and
that's exactly what I was doing and I
reached out to friends that I trusted
friends that I loved people who I knew
were dispensers of good advice and I
called them one by one and said I'm
going through this what can I do I also
reached out to friends who I knew were
going through similar things and offered
my support for them because that's one
of the things I've learned in my career
which is the best way to solve your
problems is to help people who are going
through the same thing and so to
understand how to react under extreme
stress to understand and build the
relationship so that when you do go
through something you know who to call
my rule during covet and I called all my
a-type personality friends and gave them
my rule which is there's no crying alone
and the question I would ask every one
of you is if you start to cry who are
you going to call
who will you pick up the phone and just
say I need to cry and tell them what's
going on it is much healthier to know
that someone will give you a shoulder
and be there to support you no matter
what you're going through
what I think is really interesting is
think of a date like uh uh like a job
interview right
um and think of a job interview like a
date right so
um if you went on a on a first date with
someone and they sat down they said you
know
um
I'm extremely rich
um I've made lots of money I do lots of
cool things I've met a lot of famous
people
um I go on TV all the time which is good
because I'm really good looking uh yeah
yeah would you want to go on a second
date with them right not very appealing
it's also not very appealing when we sit
down for a job interview and just tell
people how great we are and all the
things that we've done it's the same
kind of thing now imagine if you knew
you or why and you're making
conversation with someone uh and they
say so you know where are you from would
you know tell me a little bit about you
and you say you know
I love what I do I love my life I love
my job you can say I I wake up every day
to inspire people to do the things that
Inspire them and for me the challenge is
finding all the different ways that I
could do it
um and I've been really really grateful
for the path that it's taken me and I've
I've made some money and I've got to go
on TV which is fun because I'm really
good looking and you can see how all the
same jokes and all the same things now
have a context and that's what why it
does it provides context it also helps
you connect with somebody that when
somebody's telling you about themselves
and you ask some questions and you get
to know them a little bit and you
realize that maybe their values are
completely different than yours so y
gives you Clarity and confidence in who
you are and what you need around you but
it also helps you present yourself in a
way that's way more authentic now
there's a there's a there's a rub to the
why that I don't talk about that often
um uh because you really have to get
good at giving your why before you can
deal with this but the the difficult
part about knowing your why is the thing
that you give to the world the value you
give and offer to other people is also
the thing you need the most so it's one
so one of the ways to to to to
um understand the people in our lives
partners and Mates is can they actually
give us the thing that we give to other
people because you made it it this far
in a video I want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you're different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
it's a special celebration if you put a
hashtag believe down in the comments
Below on this video I will showcase you
and celebrate you somewhere on the
screen in a future video because you are
awesome for 10 more amazing rules from
Les Brown check the video right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there as you sell yourself every day
every day every day you will begin to
see a difference in the things that
you're doing selling yourself on your
ability to perform a job to achieve a
certain objective